Hello.
Hey everybody.
The Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com that's
o, n n I t, makers of Alpha
brain, which I'm on now.
Brian, are you on it? I'm on new mid
on it, bitch. Get on it. I ran out.
You bet you take the new mood because
you liked to party. You're 34.
No, it's just helps me at night. Serotonin
son. That's, that's what it
is. It really doesn't it?
When you do all that crazy shit you oh
yeah. Yeah. I didn't do it all the time.
It's like a junkie on the street. You,
I did it once the other day. Oh, okay.
Once the other day. Keep it together,
son. Um, yeah. What new mood is, is a,
it's five HTP and l trip to fan and
apparently the way the body breaks down
certain, it's all described on, on a.com.
But before I do my butcher job of
scientifically hacking through my limited
inflammation,
um,
five HTP is something that it allows your
brain to produce more serotonin and l
trip to fan converts to five HTP.
You're doing it with whiskey.
This is a perfect chase. Right? It
is the perfect that is, that is it.
You might imagine if that would
make you so drunk, happy Madge.
If it turned out that was like a
happy drunk and I'm fine with that.
I love happy drunks. Happy drunks are
really rare. I'm finding out. So knowing.
Yeah, it's super rare. So knowing people
that don't know how to handle their shit,
dirty freaks anyway on it.com
oh and n I t shroom tech sport.
That's what you needed to get on Sun man.
You need to start working out,
get your body in order kid, get your
heart pumping and I want you to die. Yeah.
You get, you listen, you need to make
it work or it's going to give out quick.
Yeah. I mean I I consider like I do
workouts but the disguised as work, like,
like going through the airport
with a studio the other day.
Like I still a workout. Yeah. I had
a boss who is kind, Kinda, yeah.
I had a box that weighed
probably 50 pounds.
I had a book bag that weighed probably
80 pounds and then I had a sore the next
day. I'm so sore right now. I
have my whole body feels fun.
But that was kind of like, let's
see, I disguise workouts like that or
take shroom tech sport before you go to
the airport. Then yeah, you should do it.
Help you for rails to cordyceps
mushrooms and beat 12. And it's a,
if anybody, do you ever
exercise? Occasionally. Yeah.
I've got to get you on some true shroom
tech sport. It's quarter steps, mushrooms,
it's fascinating stuff.
And on a.com also has kettle
bells and battle ropes in Joe.
What does a Kettlebell and what's a
battle rope? Some manly shit, son battle.
So this manly shit,
it's um,
battle ropes are fascinating.
They're giant long ropes,
like 40 feet long and you whip them
through the air and as you, uh,
you're whipping them
through the air there.
It's like incredible endurance exercise.
Incredible for your grandpa.
It's great for like muscular endurance.
It's a really crazy exercise.
Very hard to do.
And kettle bells of probably the single
piece of athletic equipment as the meow
in the background goes off.
Yeah. That, that I know of.
I think for functional strength,
that's probably the one of
the best things you can do.
It forces you to use your
whole body as one unit.
There's a fuck load of exercises that
are all available online. You can, like,
there's a lot of youtube videos and shit
and this is a lot of different programs
that people have up for free.
But if you want something
that's gonna increase your,
your athletic performance
and functional strength,
I could think of nothing better than
kettlebells. It's like, it's, for me,
it's like the best exercise I've ever
done for just for, for getting strong,
physically strong. So go
check it out. Uh, these,
these kettlebells are as cheap
as we can fucking sell them.
It's really hard to do this because
you're essentially sending cannon balls
through the mail
and that's what they are,
the giant cannon balls with handles on it.
So, uh, they like an old timey exercise.
Super Old Timey, black snakes.
Well, those old strong men dudes,
they that that was, that's like real
functional strength when those got,
you see those guys in those giant clubs,
you know,
they would like carry like a mace.
It was like a giant pole and at the end
of it was like a huge cannon ball and
they'd be wielding this and
you know this unwieldy object.
It's like great for strength
and all that old stuff.
Like it's like that's way better
than like a universal machine.
You know those machines, it
just kind of like just, hey,
you don't find yourself doing
that very well. Even if you do,
it doesn't really work that way the way
you're is. You're not balancing anything.
You're just pushing a machine.
It can be,
you could be pushing more with the
right than the left and barely can tell.
It's not, you know what I mean?
It's not the same thing when you're,
when you have to do,
like if you're going to do a bench press,
you just do bench press.
With a freeway like this,
there's a lot of athletic benefit
in having to balance things out.
That's negated when you have like the
super mechanical thing that doesn't vary
at all.
Brandon Miguel Roy's dinner,
that savage, so this is a,
there's a bunch of different,
this is a on on its website
we have a bunch of uh,
have we talked to an exercises that
show, uh, just basics of kettlebells,
how to carry out, how
to do it safely. And,
and the most important thing is to
understand that this is not like any other
exercise. Everything is
usually about, you know, like,
like controlled movements like
curls or shoulder presses.
Like that's how people
think of exercising.
But with kettlebells you go through
like long series of motions and you do
basically with your whole body,
things like Turkish getups,
you lie on your back with his big fucking
cannon ball and then you straighten
your arm up and then you slowly get up
and he stand up like that and then you go
back down,
back to the same thing,
lie on your back and push up this giant
cannonball. Oh yeah, it's awesome.
Me Put them in a bowling bag or ball bag.
That sounds dangerous.
It seems like they would probably think
you're suspicious when you're dealing
with a cannonball, sir. Oh Man.
This is a Kettlebell when I,
it's an ancient Russian form
of athletic enhancement.
Did we talk about how there's gut, you're
making a bunch of ups drivers workout
without knowing for ups drivers, calves.
I'm sorry, which I've noticed these
fucking things though. I'm telling you,
look,
if you order these kettlebells are the
best quality kettlebells we could find
the perfect.
They're exactly what you want and were
heavy as shit and they will never break.
These fucking things
will be there when they,
when they find the American civilization,
5,000 years from now,
some future scientists on hovercrafts,
they'll find these crazy fucking
cannon balls with handles on. I'm like,
what the fuck?
What are these crazy bitches up to?
That's how long those kettle bells
of you're working it out. Yeah.
It's proof that pick but big foot
existed too. Don't get squashy.
All right ladies, gentlemen, honey, honey
is here. Oh, you use the code named Rogan.
10% off all the supplements.
Uh,
you cannot get 10% off the battle
ropes and the kettle bells though,
cause we're selling them literally
as cheap as you humanly can. Um, uh,
and also first 30 pills.
There's always a money back guarantee.
If you want to buy like
Alpha brain and try it out,
it's a hundred percent money
back guarantee and you don't
even have to return it.
All you have to do is say,
this stuff sucks.
Go Fuck yourself and you
get your money and boom,
we know that we're selling good stuff
and we hope that you're going to want to
use it again so you're not
going to rip us off. Sorry.
He says that as a trip to fan.
That does, yeah, he moved. Yeah.
Doesn't that put you to sleep?
That's what I heard a trip to fan.
I think it's a real accent. Um, I don't
think it puts you street mountain,
but they think Melatonin puts you sleep.
I think that's actually a myth.
It's a myth that trip to fan put you
asleep. I believe that most people,
it's just overeating and we associate
it with the Turkey because thanksgiving,
it's the one day like you
purposely ovary like everyone.
Delicious smell of the year. Yeah, you
go fucking crazy. You completely overeat.
Ooh. It has Valerian root, which is also
a sleep aid, but then crystal meth would,
what sound, she's
fucking crazy. All right.
Start it Brian. Let's get
this fucking bitch. Rolan
experience. Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast all day.
[inaudible]
my friends, my friend. Good
to see you guys. It's fucking
supersite for this. I was, I'm
very much looking forward to it.
I really enjoyed a senior guys
on stage and Coachella from,
I've watched it online.
You did? Yeah. That's
awesome. It was awesome
line. It was fucking cool. First of
all, that's a really cool feature.
They had all the different stages,
like everything you could watch it all
go down online and I was like, wow,
that's uh, that's amazing. I think it's
the first year they did that to this.
They're, they're changing their
sit up like crazy. It's amazing.
But when you said that you used to
work there selling hot will selling
I W I was working there.
I'm southern Barbecue Selling Barbara
Baby Blues barbeque. Yeah, it was crazy.
I went just to go to the
festival. Um, but I, I
got 100 bucks for the weekend
to work and then, you know,
I stopped by Muranga on the
way to double it, triple it,
and then I hung out at the festival
and sold, you know, beef brisket.
Wow.
That's hilarious. It was cool.
And then here you were on stage.
That was like a scene in a
movie that's like finding,
that's like a cool scene in a movie.
Like when things start to
really boom for your career,
you get to say something
like that on stage.
It, you know, it was, it was intense.
It was definitely like
incredibly overwhelming in a,
in a positive and exciting way because
you get there and it's just fucking huge.
Like,
like the,
and one of the coolest parts I think about
Coachella was that the backstage area
where all the artists hang out, like the
artist's camp, um, was open to everybody.
It wasn't,
you know,
it's like the sort of like newer
bands such as ourselves over here.
It was like everybody was
walking around like Holy Shit,
there's Radiohead and there's,
there's Dr Dre and a shit
load of weed and everybody,
everybody. It was so, that was
really cool to just be like,
er amongst these people and feel like
you belong there. You know it was,
it was rad.
It was cool.
I met ice cube once he knew my name.
Of course he did. He knows
my, it's like what up Joe?
Oh today was a very good day.
Yeah.
Every time I think of ice cube and ice
tea, I think about that youtube or that,
that photograph, you know of like the
pop machine or soda machine if you will,
that has like Coca Cola.
Right.
And there's a picture of ice teas face
over the ice tea and then ice cube over
the ice cream. It's so great. Sorry.
Just so literal. Yeah. How much
she's still trip out, like running into
like really famous people like that.
And you're like, you will work working
with them. What does it, is it,
is it a mind fuck?
Like what's what's cause it's just
starting to happen for you guys.
You guys are on tour with
Sheryl Crow right now. Right.
Ben quit like the fact that she
knows our band's name right.
The mind blowing apart and then
she uses her time on stage.
She's been talking about us for like,
she'll give like these honey honey
speeches. Oh, it was amazing. I teared up,
I swear to God. Holy
Shit. She's a, you know,
she's one of the first people
we've toured with that like, I,
I mean I used to listen to her when I
was a kid and I kind of worship her a
little bit. I mean, she's, she's a
bad ass and she's, she, first of all,
she plays for like two hours in every
song is a hit. Yeah. Every song.
Jesus Christ and, and um, to be, you know,
so amazingly generous to us.
Really humbling and just like, it's,
it's pretty crazy. I had a, uh,
a friend of mine's girlfriend question
whether or not I was joking that I was
really low like that.
It was a CD in my car and I was offended.
[inaudible] it's like, how could you not
like Sheryl Crow? She's fucking awesome.
She's fucking incredible lyrics.
Like all the,
you don't really have that CD by it.
Then you were like,
no, seriously get out. How
are you fart in my space up,
dare you.
Oh my God, you guys, that's
going to be so trippy.
You're in like that really
cool stage of the movie.
That's really cool stage honestly to
be honest with you. Like seriously,
like we've toured for years now and like,
and no disrespect to the other people
we've toured with because they've been
incredible. But like from my
childhood, like listening to her,
I remember like lists like driving in the
car with my mother and like making her
harmonize with me for the show crow songs.
I'm like, no mom, you, I take the top,
you take the bottom. Then we,
we've come on and I'm just like,
do it again and do it again.
And just to watch her perform like right
in front of me and then to say to say
like, Oh, you know, you guys really need
to, we need to talk about honey honey.
And she really gave us the time up
there. Like I fucking freaked out. I was,
I was emotional about it.
It was really cool.
And you see it as a real person too.
I mean, I don't, she's very tiny,
small or in your pocket,
but it's not like this,
this product or anything like that.
You have the CD in your car,
you have a download or a video and
it's all these like representations.
But then she's right there, you know? And
she just saw her once at a Baja fresh.
Really? She was in line at the Baja
for awesome. I was like, Oh shit.
That's Sheryl Crow Burritos.
I didn't say anything though.
Most of us kept on paying
attention to what she ordered.
I remember to this day,
how many people would do that?
Me? Just kidding. Sort of money,
creepy people and would steal
her food. Ooh, just wrap it up.
Pull it out of the trash. Zip Lock
it. Yeah. Well that's like, not,
not to be disgusting,
but you know,
they talk about like the seventies
stories where like, you know,
groupies like steel condoms from like
Mick Jagger Zam and tries disgusting.
Brought that up. There's, you know,
I think it's not as rock and
roll anymore as it used to be.
The Rock and roll life is not as rock
and roll to Twitter. Ruin it. No, I mean,
I think there's just like safety
issues. It's like, you know,
don't go in the trash fishing for use
condoms. It's probably not a good move
that we've have all teacher, you
know, we figured out the fire.
I'm really sorry I don't do that.
Yeah,
don't, don't go doing that.
No, but seriously, I think
that like you can't, you know,
back in the day it was like, you know, I
don't know Metallica or somebody, whoever,
you know,
rage against the machine.
I shouldn't name names cause I don't want
to misquote anyone. But like, you know,
bigger bands would just trash a hotel
room or like the 80s it was end of the
job. You're not really saying those get
bands cause I don't know if any of those,
no, I don't. And I love those man. So
I shut my mouth. I was just looking.
I know I've done that. You've
trusted for example, and you go, uh,
but, but nowadays, if you disrespect
establishments in venues like that,
people don't want to have you back.
Even if you sell it out, it's
like you're, you know, you're the,
there's like a sort of a new
wave of, of sort of, you know,
everybody went to Rehab and then they
came back and they realize that you need
to be respectful and you know,
people are working.
That's why Joshua Volta can't get
massages at some jewelry. That's why.
That's exactly why they were like,
dude,
stop trying to fuck my staff.
Oh Man. Well that's what happens
to me. No, I'm just kidding.
We'll fucking your staff. No, they
don't let me end to get a massage.
Yeah, you can't be trash. And
People's hotel rooms, right.
That's fucking rude is shit.
I don't know.
Drew to everyone else's stay in the
hotel too. They're all going to hear that
on the table, but that's about it.
That's one of the different one.
It's like a motel six. That's
true. Like what are we going to do?
Motel six by by default.
How'd you do that? Well, um,
we had a Gig for the 4th of July
in Pagosa Springs, Colorado,
which was incredibly, you know,
just a great time. Is that near?
It's like four hours south of Denver.
Wow. Yeah, a relaxing spa town.
So it smells everywhere.
Solferino like, yes, very much so.
It's very stinky, but apparently
it's like minerals, but it's like,
it's so good for you. Yeah, it's, it's
pretty, it's funny. I, my, my buddies,
I'm staying with my friend Dave. I was
Dave, if you're watching this is hey Dave,
um,
he,
his toilet had this like backup thing
last night and it smelled horrible,
but I was like, oh, that's,
that also smells like the
hot springs from is healing,
healing. And then I, I
made, I'm just kidding.
Um, but anyway, on our way back from
this 4th of July Gig, um, we were,
uh, we were somewhere and actually we
were in a town called Mexican waters,
Arizona and we were at this gas
station. Yes. And the Navajo nation.
And in the middle of number work,
do you have to go through there?
Do you have to show id to go
through the Navajo nation?
Just drive through and you're good to go.
They want you to move there though.
That's what I was figuring out. How does
that work? Look on reservations. You know,
can you just, you could just drive in.
We just went straight through. Yeah. Hmm.
Bought some jewelry,
kept growing and they were allowed to
have totally different laws there, right?
I believe so. Yes. On reservoir.
All I know as far as my, um, my
experience with, with that sort of thing,
it has to do with casinos and yes,
they have their own law.
They have their own drone
law as far as that. Right.
If someone calls the cops on you and
you're within the reservation of,
or that territory, they have their own,
their own law or their own police force.
Yeah. That's kind of a fascinating
trip, isn't it? Yeah. It's interesting.
Dover remanence of genocide essentially.
But I think that if there's, if there's,
if there's a,
um,
there's some sort of situation
that needs to go to a higher level,
then it's a federal
case and then it's so intense.
That's why I just try to mind my p's
and q's when I'm going through a Indian
reservations. It's fascinating
though, isn't it? I mean,
it's almost like the radar that
it was all stolen, so I can't,
we'll just give you so
obvious that it was,
yeah, so obviously it was, but
there's like, is there anything,
any greater way to admit it
then to have this, you know,
areas where you'd like to have a
country inside of country side,
so they're allowed to, you know, gambling
is cool. We like gambling. Come on in.
Federal aid works with that though.
That's a different thing because you
have all these other places that are
getting by from federal aid, but then
you say, hey, you do your own thing. I,
you know, like it would federal
aid can't fuck with gambling money.
Gambling money is way
more than federal aid.
If you had to choose between getting
federal aid or the fucking Kazillions that
casinos Raykin yeah. You know,
when you look at casinos,
there's a reason why they're so
big. Yeah. Ran Places. But it's,
it's such a change. There is such a huge
gap from the top and the bottom. Yeah.
You know,
the people that actually own the casinos,
a lot of tribes are actually
by birth. Right? You're part
of the casino. Some very,
very small tribes. Um, like there's
a tribe, but he gets a check. Yes.
That's sweet. Shockapy if you're
shockapy Indian your hours, just really,
yeah. I tried, I tried to prove it was me.
I was like, come on, don't you see them?
Nothing. No one, no DNA
test. What if, I mean,
can they prove it? How
can they prove it? Um,
and so just like you have to have
some sort of a family tree. Yeah.
There's gotta be some sort
of registration, no proof.
I actually have no idea to be
honest. I mean, yeah. I, I don't,
I haven't figured it out.
It is a trip.
So when you think about the fact
that there's nations within a nation,
there's Indian reservations. It's like,
it's a really weird, it is interesting.
A lot of fights there. When
a California, when marrow,
when mixed martial arts was illegal,
they used to have these fights in the,
any casinos. Really the only
places that all men, yeah,
the Indian casinos would let them come
and we would do like three of the key
ones that
I guess it was the 90s Oh,
it was illegal in the 90s
I didn't know that. Yeah,
like the late nineties the UFC came about
in [inaudible] 93 and it was illegal
here.
After that.
It was like you could go and then
they got sanctioned and when they got
sanctioned that now like we
have fights here all the time.
I was going to be one next
weekend actually. A or August, uh,
August 3rd or fourth on Fox. So I'm
like, they have him here all the time,
but not back then you used to have to
go to these casinos were like in the
middle of nowhere.
You would drive like way deep down these
weird fucking roads in the middle of
nowhere and you'd find this casino and
that's what they'd have king of the cage
and it would be in a parking
lot. And they fought out, right?
Oh Man. Fight Club style.
They fun outside rock,
which is what we're organizing illegally.
And one time these were fighting in
a Sydney cause you know,
in the rain on this slippery surface.
So they're like throwing punches and
flying through the air and slipping and
sliding all over the place.
Companies fracturing, pouring
rain. It sounds horrible.
Ridiculous, ridiculous. But I mean that
was the kind of shit that was going on,
you know?
And they were,
they were allowed to do that only
because it was Indian reservations.
Really nuts. Stop and think about it. They
would do, the Indians were like, come on,
it will take your money.
Come on in. And Dude,
they had no problem with it.
You know, like, why are you
guys paying such pussies?
And meanwhile,
they were right.
Man, there's, it's a, it's
such an interesting subject
because like, you know,
I'm really into the show deadwood. Oh,
the HBO show. Yeah. I'm obsessed with it.
I, I fixed myself a whiskey and I
watch it for maybe more than a whisky.
Um, and it's, you know, it's
beautifully shot and um, you know,
but it's about deadwood. The town,
um, was in Montana. It's Montana
or Wyoming, Wyoming Shit. I should know
this as a diehard fan. What an idiot.
Um, but anyway, it, uh, one of those old
west, yes at the time, but, you know,
it was one of the last sort of
re one of the last towns. Um,
that was sort of its own
law, which is why, you know,
it's so wild and there's all these crazy,
you know, there's real cowboys, right?
Real cowboys on TV. Um, but you know,
that when they're also, you know,
in contention with, with, you know,
local tribes and things, and there's,
there's these gnarly fights and, you know,
it's, it's a, it's fictitious as a
television show, but it's also, you know,
real in a sense that that was, that
actually happened at one point. It's,
it's a really interesting sentiment
to sort of really let sink in.
And it makes me really sad,
you know, because they were,
they were just outcast and,
you know, then, then they
were on these reservations.
And, you know, when you drive through
there, it's a really interesting,
interesting thing because there's
casinos and, and then there's,
there's these beautiful
historical, um, you know, uh,
monuments and things, and like,
there's art, there's music, there's,
there's traditional elements. Um, and I,
it's really, it's like this, like you're,
you're sort of juxtapose next to the
traditional historic part and then the
casinos and then like, what's happening
now, which is a lot of poverty. Um,
and so it's, it's really, it's really
a weird paradox to be in, you know,
when you're going through there. And we
travel all the time. Um, but you know,
not to, not to go back to
where I started, but, um, the,
the story was when we were talking about,
um,
messing up a motel six hotel room,
when we were going through
a Navajo Indian country,
we stopped at this gas station
and, um, I picked up a dog.
Um, she's, she's this new
little part of my life. Um,
somebody left her there for a
week and, um, it was really, yeah,
yeah, she's, she's amazing. Um,
and she just ran up to me and
like Kinda gave me like a,
like a little dog hug and I was like,
oh, whoa, whoa, Whoa, what are you doing?
And you know, the, the people of the,
the gas station, we're like, yeah,
she's been here a week, you know,
people drop their dogs all the time.
And I was like, oh, people can
suck it. I'm taking the dog.
But our first night with her,
she,
I think she was freaked out because she
was outside for a week and, you know,
eating out of dumpsters.
And then, um, you know,
we brought her in the hotel room and
I had her outside for like 20 minutes.
I was trying to get her to go to
the bathroom. It wasn't happy.
She wasn't going all day, all day. We,
we thought we thought she was
pregnant and I was like, oh no,
this is going to be really bad. Um,
and then when we stopped at this,
this Walmart to get the
necessary accoutrements for
dogs, like, you know, treats,
leashes,
I'm in the parking lot of the Walmart.
She took the biggest dog
shit I've ever seen take.
And I needed two bags and it
was like five pounds disgusting.
But then she didn't look
pregnant. I was like, she looks
starving, but you know, we,
we took her around and, you
know, we basically, um, we're,
we're trying to get her to go.
And she,
she sort of went a little bit and I
think she was freaked out. But uh,
to make a long story short, in the middle
of the night, she hopped up, not even,
we all went to bed. She, she hopped
in bed with our tour manager.
And just peed like,
like in like gallons.
And this was after we'd,
you know,
we'd wash just as clumps of hair
washed or who was, he was a big deal.
She's a wild dog essentially. I
don't think she's, she definitely,
she is now. She is. That was the only
time I've seen her just be an asshole.
And I was like, her name is Louise
and I was like, what the Fuck Louise,
you have some manners to
the Shell gas station?
No Way. No Way. No Way. I mean,
who hasn't peed the bed at some point,
right?
You probably, you probably
need to live a little more sun.
We should really challenge
ourselves, Ben, and you know,
really just drink ourselves calls.
Do you get though?
We think about peeing in a dream
and you're like, you motherfucker.
And then you wake up that I felt that
in my adulthood. I'm not going to lie.
It creeps,
creeps,
creeps right up to the
door. It's like, man,
maybe we just go into this breath real
quick and P and I'll walk in and zip.
I go,
I'm not in a bathroom while I'm sleeping.
Mother fucker get angry.
Do you have an enlarged?
No, it seems pretty normal, but
it's, you know, there you go.
I talk in my sleep. That's
as far as it goes. You know,
I full on discussions.
I could have a full on conversation
with someone and not know it and it was
truthful, which is, you
know, when I should stop.
Here's kind of fascinating
though that you can have,
I mean I think most of us have had that
happen in some time in your life where
you thought you were at a bathroom
and your dream and you peed.
I haven't done that.
Never when you were a little kid thing.
So I actually peed in like where I woke
up and I'm like, I'm peeing right now.
This is crazy. I mean I do that
like you know, once a week.
But where are you in bed when this is
how many going you imagine if like Brian
just came out and told us he pisses
the bed once a week. That's so funny.
It's like totally normal. I'm
driving right now. He has a little,
have you ever had a pee in the car?
Never had a piano car.
I peed out of my door while
dries into a bottle. God,
that's impressive.
And you just hadn't cracked
peed in a Gatorade bottle.
You just got to.
Exactly.
I think it's like, you know, if
you're, if you're stuck in the car
and you and you don't do that,
your options are pissed all over yourself.
[inaudible] break something internally.
Right. It's hard to know where that line,
right. Where is, are you being a
pussy? A little bit of pampering?
Oh yeah, for sure. We have
a nozzle. I'm definitely,
I've definitely had some got to
run over and actually when we were,
we played Sasquatch.
I went and peed behind a haystack
and I felt really good about it.
I felt like it was really authentic for
the festival that we were playing and I
was really in a bad spot.
I had to go,
one of my favorite moments of travel
and meeting random people that has to do
with a Girl Ping in front of a hotel.
There were,
I was with mark the Hammer Coleman.
He's just a UFC heavyweight champion dude.
And me and him,
there was a,
we were at this weird little
strip club place in uh, Augusta,
Georgia and this is like,
we've been there.
The pink pony that's
in Atlanta is like 96,
maybe somewhere around then
the sex.
And um,
there's this girl that's working there
and she's got really stinky breath and
she keeps trying to,
Oh that's me. It was terrible.
It was what? She was really good
aggressive and she was one of those girls.
It was like a white girl,
but she talks like a
black girl and she's like,
oh you don't even know what the
fuck y'all missing. You know,
you don't even know what the fuck you.
So she winds up,
mark winds up leaving,
we wind up,
this girl is friends with a
girl that is with mark. So
this girl stuck with her in the car. She's
wearing wrestling pants or wrestling,
wrestling shoes and sweat pants and shit.
The whole time we're in the car.
You don't know what
the fuck y'all missing.
You don't know what that was the
beef sandwich you had for lunch?
Cause I can smell it. It was the most
ridiculous thing ever. We get to the hotel
and mark grabs his friend and bails
leaves this like literally,
literally grabs her and runs with
her and this one is stuck outside,
so she's like,
I need to know where mark the mother
fucking hammer Kallman's room is.
She's like yell in the lobby.
They kicked her out of the hotel.
She pulls down her pants and pulls
down her periods. She's p right.
And like the foyer area.
She got me out passing in
the street like I'm some kind
of fucking animal. Oh my God.
I hope you videotape that knows
there was no videos back in 1996 wow.
To have a fucking camera with you back
then. You'll be carrying some with phs.
Yeah. Big Ass. Big Ass taping it. Wow.
I'll never forget her. I'll never
forget her. She was sober, right? Yeah,
they should. They kicked her out when
they were trying to kick her out.
You wanted to use the bathroom,
which is one of the things that people
will do to try to regain control.
Like if you getting kicked out
of a bar. Okay, okay, I'll leave.
Let me use the bathroom first.
I'll leave.
So it's like you get to leave sort of
on your terms. You get a little dignity,
get a little power back. That's what
she was going to tip. She's like,
she's like,
well they were kicking her out.
I need to know where I marked a
mother fucking Hammer Coleman's rooms.
They're like, ma'am, you have
to leave. You have to leave in.
The security came over.
So I lead but I need to use a bathroom.
I need to use the bathroom.
And like she really did have
to leave it after she did.
She squatted down and pushed her sweat
pants for us so she wouldn't be on him.
I'll never forget the,
the, the river of pis.
I'll never forget standing there
shaking my head. That sounds adorable.
It was fantastic.
I wish I knew her name cause I could
follow her on Facebook cause I know she
says some awesome shit.
Oh,
you know y'all got me out of here passing
in the street block on some kind of
fucking animal. Never forget that. Like,
like follow. Yeah, yeah, please.
Yeah. And those are fun. Road stories
are the best. There's so many, you know,
you meet the most interesting people
and only for a second, you know. Um,
and uh,
yeah.
Do you find it weird how different the
vibe is from city to city that the cities
are so it's very, it's so
interesting isn't it? You're
like regionally, it's, yeah,
it's really bizarre when you try to
absorb the whole United States as a whole
and try to just wrap your head around how
many different communities and entails
how huge it really is and how,
and how
different it really is in different
parts. It's, it's amazing. I, I have, uh,
I prefer those. No. You know, the sort
of like peeing in the middle of the,
the foyer or a lobby area moments,
which is usually some of,
you know, you're in the deep south and
that's, there's some fun happening.
Hopefully nobody gets shot.
Hmm. I feel like not, you know,
I love the South Africa and obviously I'm
not, you know, calling out, um, you know,
public urinating.
But like,
I find that I'm in this southern style,
you find a lot more sort of a candid
kind of person that, you know, there's,
there's all these puns and things
that are so brilliant yet so simple,
you know, like, like, you know,
sweating like a whore in church.
That's my favorite of swing.
No horns. Like, yeah, that
really is a southern thing.
That's another thing. And there's
still, I mean, they're infinite.
There's so many of them. And I just,
I want to go down there and your puns,
you know, I wanna, I
wanna, I wanna learn the,
the southern vernacular and it's like an
arsenal of all these amazing things and
yeah.
You know, there's, we have a
good one. I card broken down
in the parking lot of this place because,
uh,
we were just waiting for AAA or something
to come and then we roll into this
sandwich spot. It was a subway, possibly.
So it might've been a Blimpie or
something like that. Doesn't matter.
The point is, and uh, the, these
two people, once we had ordered the,
the woman who was making the sandwiches
in the sky, I'd walked in the door,
just started bringing up the
Lorena Bobbitt story or something.
Lisa,
I think the,
Lorena Bobbitt had been released from
prison or something or something had
happened or, or a Bobbitt uh, the,
the man had done a porno or something.
Like there was something that he had done,
something that had happened in the
media that the name was relevant. Yeah.
But yeah, and there's just conversing
and then you know, it gets,
this poem is woman. She's sitting there
cutting a roast beef and she goes, yeah,
she just,
through that Dick in the middle of the
highway, how often do you hear that?
Do that dig in the middle of the
highway and almost it on his bitch.
I like, do you want extra meanings?
Yeah. And some chipotle sauce.
That's the south certainly has a lot
of flavor. I love it. I love it. Yeah.
I'm a big fan of Texas. Favorite
places to perform. It's great.
And I did my last special in Atlanta.
Did you land with the shit?
That's probably been the place we
spend the most time it struck great.
I'm a strip cause with this place called
the pink pony, Costco Strip clubs.
There was like the Walmart,
Costco,
there's every, every flower and just
everything you want. It was our first,
it was our first strip club experience.
We, yeah. W for me. Was He not you?
It was mine. We, we're just, we are
with our first record company. Um,
and there, um, are you familiar with
the band jackal? I've heard the name.
So you know it was a, with 80s, 90s,
80s, 80s and 90s. 80s, 90s. Yeah.
I think he cock rock his cock cock
rock. Yeah, he would call it that. Okay.
Well there's a member of the band
is, he's the lead singer. Yeah,
Jesse James Dupree. How many people are
right now? Dude, you don't know who?
Jacqueline Jackal. Well, Jesse James
Dupree is, is it an unbelievable,
amazing human being in it and a
good friend of ours. And He, um,
he actually was affiliated with
our record company. Um, and um,
by the way, he plays the chainsaw. Huh?
He plays a chainsaw on stage.
He had created a guitar out of a chainsaw.
There's not too much of a, of a two
notes that's harmonious, um, you know,
addition to the music. But it's more
of like it's a real chainsaw and he,
he will play it and then he'll usually
like shred things like a wooden chair on
the stage.
We were opening for our
friend Rocco Deluca and Jesse
James came out on shredded
things and it's fucking terrifying cause
please, please don't cut your leg off.
Oh my, Oh my God. He just,
how is that legal? I don't know.
Yeah, it just kind of happened,
but they're playing this like dirty
blues rock down to the I am damn damn to
contain and he just goes wrong.
Dual apart. That is so crazy.
Yeah. What does the audience go?
Bananas. You have skin. It's
insane. How can you not that
must go ape shit. But the,
but afterwards they took us in a
like a banana, yellow limousine
from like the night like
eighties or nineties, like a
old limo, like, like stretch,
limo. We get picked up, um, by Jesse
and there they are. There he is.
Oh my God.
Oh my God. I'm on with
the, so I can hear it. Oh,
there it is
beyond awesome. Jesse j. That man
took us to our first,
my first strip club experience,
man.
He can really belt it.
He's very a AC dcs.
Yeah.
Yes, yes. They have a huge
following. I mean they,
I think they tore every summer for
like a month or so. Um, but he,
he's incredible. And so we, we did like
a, we were in Atlanta for like 10 days,
like four years ago, um, five
years, probably longer than that.
But five or six years ago
we were brand spanking new.
Like we hadn't even done
our first record yet.
We're just trying to figure out
how to, you know, we're like, okay,
I guess this is what bands do.
And we get picked up by Jesse James
Dupree in a yellow taxi stretch limo. But,
uh, you know, from the 1991.
So it's a real old looking
vehicle and there's,
there's a case of Miller
lite and he's like, you know,
we're going to the Strip club. And I just
like, I remember being like, is this,
it's like I think this is
what we're supposed to do.
We're supposed to fucking get down
and like, and then like, you know,
flash cut to like these fucking huge
tits in my face and I'm getting my first
lap dance okay for by another record exec.
And you know,
she kind of bit my neck and that was
fine, you know. But it was just like,
he was really weird and she
and I smelled like her later.
You like wow. Okay. But um,
it's a weird thing. Yeah, it's a
weird thing. It was like 21 years old.
Their bakery, strange light, Gray area,
you know, cause it's not prostitution.
No, but an intimate moment,
they're intimate with you for money. Like
they want to get close to you. I mean,
it's nothing wrong with it. There's
nothing wrong with it. And it like,
I don't think there's anything
wrong with prostitution.
I think if you want to do it,
I don't, I don't recommend it.
But I would say that there shouldn't
be laws against it. Legalize it. Yeah.
If there's not laws
against fucking people,
why should they be laws against
fucking people for money? That's crazy.
That doesn't make any sense. It's
like just, it should be legal. I mean,
I'm not saying you should do it.
You definitely shouldn't do it.
Don't do the freedom. I don't know how
I feel about it to be honest with you.
I'm just kind of like, you know, just uh,
I just think the last
care of everybody took
care of yourself.
But I think the last like laws like that,
like why you most says, cause it doesn't
restrict anything. It just still happens.
Then this happens the league and he just
happened to illegally and then people
are doing things in a risky, isn't it
legal troubles in Nevada? No, it's not.
It's legal. It's legal in certain
parts of Nevada. Very small area.
We did a thing for it and the man
shows like, it's like a one county,
I think it's really
okay.
That's really interesting.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
It's really interesting because
that particular brothel,
if he willing to be to throw
back, um, is, is very, you know,
it looks like they have a nice system,
you know,
as far as being clean
and, and safe, you know,
the clients that come in, you know, it's
not like how's it getting, you know,
cut. Yeah. I mean look, you should be
able to, if that's what you want to work,
you should be able to work there. It seems
to me that you're not hurting anybody.
It's the music thing does, if our
Kickstarter account doesn't take off guys,
I will be in the check book and find
me in that one county in Nevada and um,
don't tease with Keven you,
he's like,
that's all there is a little baby steps.
I don't want to be a clerk in a seven 11,
although actually I,
but before we do that, I would love
to work at trader Joe's, trader Joe's,
they all think very happy that everybody's
so happy. They're healthy food.
Probably get a discount.
If they didn't hire me,
I would definitely end up in that brothel.
Definitely there's not a lot of
options here were pretty obvious.
That's where it'd be weird
when you watch those movies,
the old west and they always had a brothel
and it was always like every fucking
street was exactly the same.
It was a dirt road and there was a bunch
of buildings real close to each other
on one side and a bunch.
And that was the whole fucking town.
I mean it was like the most
unoriginal architecture set up ever.
And it was like the dumbest
engineering one straight town.
There was your breath holders
you're building right now. It's fun.
Entertainment has no bounds.
You know what I mean?
Like there's so many different
flavors now. Must've sucked.
So hard to be stuck in the wild west.
Could you imagine how
bad or very little laws?
I mean it's just people
were killing each other. We
had to get used to body odor cause I'm
sure people smelled fucking terrible all
the time.
And they were all
three where it was an actual reality
that people would have draws.
They would draw each other and see who
could pull their gun out the quickest.
And shoot you, that was an actual
reality that there were guns
by a lot of town.
You get killed by bandits or something
or the Indian tribe that you stole the
land from, he's going to kill Ya.
Yeah, and there's a lot of those towns,
they did a make it,
they just,
they were there for a little while and
then the mine dried up or whatever the
fuck was dragging people.
They're dried up and that's it.
And then you could go through a
whole town and see, oh, real ghosts.
It's fascinating. Ooh, you
can feel the energy. It's,
it's pretty wild at sounds so hippy dippy.
But there's a guy that named Rupert
Sheldrake and I think he believes that
there's some type of memory in
everything and he is in the eye.
The idea is that like,
like even objects like the,
the actually do contain
some sort of memory.
That's why people get creeped out in
a house where someone was murdered.
You don't want,
even though I happened a long time ago,
you don't want to be in that house.
You don't want to be in that spot.
It was like New York City.
I feel like there's such a powerful
energy there because there's so much
residual memory there. You know what I
mean? It's like there's definitely that.
There's an energy to it. Right.
Where were we? We were there, uh,
like a couple months ago we
were on tour and um, you,
we were stopping to get some lunch and
in the middle of, um, I'm not sure,
like mid town area.
It wasn't there.
There's this like cemetery literally in
the middle of tiny little cemetery in
the middle of the block.
And it was so interesting because
I think it was sanctioned off.
Like you couldn't build anything there.
It was,
it was legitimately protected and
he was so like, it was from like,
was it like the 18 hundreds?
Yeah.
Well then you realize all these towns
like New York used to be a city like that
town. I mean it was, it wasn't
just one member gangs in New York.
That was pretty awesome. Awesome.
Cameron Diaz redhead. Yeah. What?
Yeah. Daniel Day Lewis got us
killing mother fuckers. God Damn,
that dude's a bad motherfucker.
That movie. Jesus Christ,
would it build the butchers?
I went, his name was,
that was what New York was really likely.
You think of New York.
It's always being like, hey,
beep Hong Kong. No, no, no, no.
They were on the fucking horses band.
They started out on horsepowers. Yeah.
With cleavers jacking each other.
They're on the streets.
Have you read any Caleb car books? No.
There's a book called the elitist. Um,
and then, um, yeah, Angel of darkness,
darkness is the other one. Um, but he,
he's an incredible author and had written
these amazing stories about New York
in a very dark, um, but, uh, circa
crime novels or historical crime novels.
They're amazing. And it's like this,
it puts you in this world,
the late 18 hundreds in New York City.
Um,
and,
and it bases around this figure who
using psychology to solve these serial
killings for the first time.
You know,
like the first time the psychology and
psychiatry is used to analyze these
crimes.
Um,
anyway. But yeah, but like the visual
of the town is pretty wild because it's,
he uses actual,
um,
like actual places that were
relevant to the time and it's,
you know, it's pretty,
pretty interesting. You know,
there's a lot of gangs like things
in New York and things like that.
Cocaine and prostitution and you know,
all the great things that are
happening now forcibly less,
right. They were, they were
crazy back then. There's a lot,
I mean the idea of living in sort
of a semi lawless place like that,
we just had to kind of
count the sheriff to right a
wrong and go get this poor guy and he's
ready to retire and he's got a stupid
gold star on like in the movies.
And that's what life on the road is like.
Wait, looking out for the sheriff, who
is the sheriff and honey honey? Oh God.
I don't know. Maybe you guys having a
power struggle right in front of me.
Definitely not to play tennis.
This morning
I was up three games. It was up three
nothing and I was fucking killing it.
And then I got cocky and it's my fault,
but you know what I can you say
it's your fault if he says, well,
I got cocky and then my niece and I
couldn't get those far right shots and it
was, I lost six, three
and I felt like a chump.
It seems like you're to
get really mad at it.
Didn't talk to Ben for like an hour.
You getting mad when you lost.
I was really compounders of the above.
That was a big moment
for me because I know
some people have to learn how to not
be angry at people when they play games
with them. I Games is when I was a
little kid. I used to have that. Yeah,
would be angry if I played a game with
someone and they beat me and be hungry.
You know what's funny? I only do, I only
do that with Ben. I swear to God though.
You weren't really upset
at him for an hour.
We know I was upset with myself
and I was like kind of a game. No,
not really.
She's entitled to beating me real like,
but she's not beating me something.
And you say
why
new moods working?
Yeah,
it's already kicking off the whiskey.
Um, how long have you
been playing tennis? Um,
I don't know. I mean I didn't play
well when I retired as a professional,
dammit.
Probably like six or seven years,
you know.
But like recreationally speaking,
something that always looked really fun
to me. It's really great. It's great.
It's great workout. I played it
once. Total body kind of thing.
My friend rich syslog is a really good
tennis player. I played with him once.
That's it.
I don't know to be honest with you.
It's really fun.
We actually started playing as a band
because both our bass player and drummer
play and you know when you're on the road
you have very few opportunities to get
physical exercise. I mean those should
be a good way to get it out. Yeah,
we have a really good time. So the
whole competitive thing is harmless.
It's just kind of funny.
There's like you have these
little championships within
yourself where I'm like,
I am going to beat Ben because I,
I need this.
I'm going to play the solo tonight.
Not Allowed to talk into the mic.
Guys have negotiations. That's kind
of cool. Have like rock, paper,
scissors to what songs do it
onstage all the time. It's really,
you guys seem to get along really well
for a guy and a girl in a band together.
I mean that's,
we were just talking about
that actually because it's,
it's really difficult right now.
There's, there's a lot of, um,
I've been a real asshole. No, you
haven't. You're fucking great.
I've been the assholes. I was such a
Dick on the way over here. I was so,
so basically we're dealing, we
really did. I was, I was like,
I wanted to kick my dashboard.
I was, because I haven't
slept for like three days.
We, we'd been on the road and you know
where you draw sometimes you drive after a
show and then you get to a
hotel. And like, in my mind,
I'm like, you have to sleep.
If you don't sleep,
you're gonna be fucked tomorrow.
And then I'm thinking about sleeping,
I don't sleep.
And then you get exhausted.
And with exhaustion comes like a
slight bout of depression. And I'm,
I'm not a really, I'm not a depressed
depressive person when I am,
I have to like really tackle it. Right.
Cause I want to, I want to rise above. Um,
but it, it's definitely, um,
another element that you really have to
contend with on the road because you're
constantly in these uncomfortable
positions. You're not eating well,
you're not sleeping,
you're,
you're playing every night and you're
traveling and you're like in a van for
eight hours, sometimes 10, 12
hours depending on the drive,
which is part of where we're at.
And part of why we should talk about our
Kickstarter campaign, um, because it's,
it's, you know, where
we're at basically. But I,
I was kind of a monster
on the way over here.
We were in bumper to bumper
traffic and I was not to you,
it was mainly mainly about myself. I
was, I don't attack you or your person,
but,
but we were talking about how,
how funny it is that after being
a band for like seven years,
we're pretty resilient. Like we don't,
you know, at the end of the day,
like Ben's my best friend and I love him
and I don't want to make him feel bad
or hurt him ever.
Well,
I feel like that's why we've been able
to be a band for seven years because we'd
just been fighting the whole God damn
time. That's how it works. You're stupid.
You're stupid. You're figuring
out how to make up every time.
You know what I mean?
It's like what are the biggest thing?
What are the fights usually about?
The lives is a very well, both.
The first thing that comes
to mind is driving. Um, I
usually I get mad at you. You
fine with it. Yeah. We fight a lot
in the car when it's like turn left,
you know, that kind of shit. That's loud,
fun, know. That's always really fun.
It's like the stupid shit.
It's stupid. It's, you know.
Did you guys watch our video?
No, not yet. Oh, what is this?
That's our Kickstarter video.
I should go to the bathroom now.
What is the Kickstarter thing
about? What's it about? Well,
you should watch it and then I guess we'll
talk about will this bit because some
of these people are, listen, ready.
We need money for our next tour.
I love you too and
so brave.
So brave.
No, we're sorry we
didn't tell you. This is
for folks. They have a chicken and
the roots. Lipstick on their face.
Donkey Guru.
They're about to have sex with a donkey.
Travel hundreds of miles to see you.
We are on a dark path
and you seek your counsel
in exchange for your advice.
We offer you the body of Suzanne,
my band mate and friend. She
is a young woman. New Bile,
great
flexible,
a donkey guru.
We're actually on offering the body of
Suzanne and I think who my associate
meant to say is he's
offering his own body to you.
I'm positive. That's what he meant.
She talked about it. Absolutely.
You know, we didn't talk about this at
all, but I didn't figure it out. I know.
I don't think, I think that's a
terrible idea of whether the chicken,
it's a rooster.
Whenever
in exchange for your pearls of wisdom
nuggets, we would like to offer
a very warm and loving companion,
violet von Rooster.
Stein a violet has been with
us for the past 47 days.
We found him in New Mexico. We hope
you humbly accept this is off right?
That'd be cool.
Flowing with
the roasters
going towards the donkey and
they were on their knees.
Now the donkey is having sex
with the rooster for your audio.
He liked it. Take your time. Donkey.
He's still having sex with it.
He's slow.
First thing I love,
how high were you guys when you made those
high points? I mean, it really
showcases Ben's acting skills.
This is one of the weirdest fucking
thing I've ever seen in my life.
That doesn't give the one last thing.
We can offer you our
most prized possession.
Oh, we took a little, but that's fine.
We share it with you this way.
Take this piece of our heart and
we're just looking for answers.
Guys gives the Jack Daniels dunking.
Be The fucking Jack. Dan, how
do we get back to the raw?
Ooh, stocky. We're sorry
if we've wasted your time,
but this isn't for us. You don't
have the answers we're looking for.
We're going to go now.
Thank you and good.
No, you know what? Fuck you.
You guys,
you guys play not,
you guys might be crazy.
There's a purpose to this.
If you've made it this far,
you are either a die honey honey
or you're just really into donkeys,
which is understandable because
the donkey is a magnificent beasts.
We created this Kickstarter project
to fund are rigorous and also vigorous
touring schedule, which as emotionally
priceless as it is, which is the truth,
has left a gaping black hole
where the money should be. Um,
life's hard. You gotta roll with
it. You've got to roll with it. Um,
our goal is to raise $17,000.
This will cover our van rental.
Our tour manager are stalwart
bandmates Patrick Taylor,
also known as [inaudible] jazz
and Jerry Porter, uncle Jaggedy,
Jay eggs, also gas and merchandise. Yes.
We're so thankful for all the
support we've gotten this far.
We just want to keep making this music,
uh, performing it all over the country.
He may be the why and whether you donate
money or just send your happiness and
good vibes and love.
We are overjoyed to be reaching him.
Touching you,
touching you
touched by you.
You've definitely touched us.
Record guy
guys. Really a doctor.
There's something going on.
I'm going to refresh it now because
this hasn't been refreshed. Oh my God,
that's fantastic.
I'm on to make a deal.
No,
that's good.
That's really good were but honestly
it's just what people are doing now.
Oh yeah. Is this the new thing? Yeah.
We've been like one of it's
creating like the last six months.
I feel like all of these people are
coming out with these kickstarters and so
how does it work?
It's like you just,
you tell them like say like you want a
pizza and like do you want to order a
large piece? You don't have any money
put in Kickstarter saying like, Hey,
I helped me buy this pizza
people and if I can make $15,
I'll let you have a bite.
If you're anywhere near me and then
they give you $15 and then you go by.
We actually have an incredible
reward system. Um, it's really fun.
I swear to God you were talking about
workouts earlier. Um, I mean the top,
the top reward for, I feel like I
should go from the bottom and start,
but the biggest reward is
if someone donates $1,000,
which is incredible, you know,
donation unless you a player.
What I mean?
Damn well there you go up and drop it.
K One cane on honey, honey man. What up?
Other than all the rewards
beneath the thousand dollars,
which are really fun workout video
specifically to you as warriors
of the road, we have effective
and innovative measures to stay in
a quasi peak physical condition.
Employing tactics like sarcasm,
cloying, temptation and yelling.
Let us see your Billy blanks.
You guys are ridiculous.
What is wrong with you guys?
Times different.
I have a question that what it is
or is it just your silly $500 one?
It says you get a half hour Skype with
whiskey and with hangout with Suzanne and
Ben's. Eat your, your, you get to Cam with
you now. Ben, do you have to be there?
I do actually.
What is the over under
stop too?
What's the over under on Dick Pics?
I don't know. How many are you
gonna get in return? Hello?
Can you see them as they see you sweat?
That could waste,
cause I didn't see a lot of ducks.
I haven't camped in a while,
but half hour with whiskey.
I think I might get a little weird.
Have you heard this
Facebook push? They're uh, they're,
they're trying to get people to log in
the youtube comments through Facebook.
So you use your own identity
now it's kind of interesting.
I like that idea. Yeah, that
would stop a lot of cons. Yeah.
Stop a lot of Cantinas.
Yeah.
What if you found out the conti has
comments where by someone, you know,
you're like Q sata had
the worst news of a patch.
Cool comments can really,
really get under your skin,
but you really need to be the
better man and walk away. You do.
But it's a fascinating thing that
the people can just reach out to you.
What did we find out?
It's all just one person,
like the chocolate rain dude or
something like that. I met him, Brian,
we did this. I'm one of those things.
Weird things for Twitter was for Twitter,
right? It wasn't a tweet. The
Twitter fest or some of fast, yeah.
Who made the chocolate rain guy?
You gotta Pee Rocket
Chocolate Rain Guy and
we haven't talk about you
by the way. FYI. If Brian gives
you a chocolate bar, how was it?
And it says only eat half.
I would say only eat a quarter.
It's, you know, it's like,
it's like you're trying to do a bear,
run up an icy mountain.
That's what it's like.
Your eyes were his life.
Oh my God.
It's probably as high as I've
ever been on earth doing a,
yeah. Making your own bars. No,
he just needed some. We were,
we were talking about how ridiculous
these things are because you never know
what the actual dosages as part of
the problem with a peanut illegal.
Well you do regulate it either.
This is like the La speed weed and on
the back it says 17% THC and it tells you
that the amount that's in it, but you
have no idea what that means. It's like,
oh yeah,
it's 17%
THC. Well, we live literally in
the wild west of weed. I mean,
this is a crazy time.
There's never a
timeline that we can go to a store and
there's hundreds of them and you just buy
the weed like that. That's it. That should
even exist. Look at it that it says,
actually it says right here,
it says pat package contains
a 1.5 grams of Skywalker Oji.
So these gummy bears, I'll give you an
idea. One point. Yeah. We eat all of them.
Yeah. If you need all these sort of
[inaudible], what does a normal winter,
what's your Candy Bar State?
How many grams is that? Oops,
sorry. Uh, this contains, uh,
where's it say, did they actually have
to do that? Is that like a new thing? No,
I think that they just do it. The
Elliot speed, we'd people. Oh, okay.
So there's some people who
have like a system. Yeah.
So you just got to get to
use to their system. Right.
Because you never really know.
It's the weirdest thing.
Like you can buy from someplace, the
first of all, the people that work there,
daycare. But if you work at a weed
store, chances are you go deep,
you know, chances are you go really deep.
So they go, well I would say eat a half.
Don't listen to them.
Don't listen too much.
This is a one ounce.
Oh man,
no, just kidding. How are you guys
taking edibles? I just got back.
What's happening?
Yeah.
Yeah. Unfortunately I think we took
a little too much. Oh, do you want
chocolate? No, I,
I recently had a very troubling experience
with that. With an edible. Yeah.
No, I don't really smoke weed that
often. Like I'll, I'll hang sometimes,
but I kind of just turned
into it an idiot. Right.
And when we were at Coachella,
my buddy gave me a jolly rancher and,
um, I, you know, never, I've rarely,
like maybe like every once in a while,
you know, smoke a little bit. Yeah.
And they were like, take
half. And I was like, well, I
can't really fucking bite it,
so I'll just take the whole thing.
I was so fucking high.
I was so excited to see Radiohead
for the first time. And I was, I was,
I was upfront, like thank God. Like they,
they did this incredible thing where they
gave you an artist viewing area and it
was right up front.
And I literally felt like I was floating
above them and I was freaking out.
Wow. It was amazing. Actually. You know
what? I'll be honest with you. I'll,
I'll totally out myself as a
girl. Um, how dare you. The,
the super fucking foxy dude from
true blood was standing next to me.
The the, which Werewolf? The Werewolf.
His name's Joe mentioned Leonoda Leo.
He's a beautiful man.
And you know,
you could tell he probably uses
a kettle ball bell, kettle bell.
So let's talk about his, his
incredible, um, and muscles.
No, I didn't meet him. I was just
high as a kite and I was by myself,
which was probably stupid on my part.
And I looked to my right and
he's standing next to me. I went,
oh my God. And then he looked
at me and I, no, you did.
Yes, I did. And then he
kind of slowly started.
I started to like drift through the
crowd and I was like, oh my God.
Like I've dreamed about this moment.
This is not how it's supposed to go.
It's supposed to involve a lot of other
things that are really exciting and
incredible and it didn't happen and
I was just mortified and how it,
yeah.
What a fucked up time to meet.
I hope that there are second
chances out there. Let me tell you,
but I found Ben and I was like, Ben,
you can meet me. I can't feel my face.
Yeah, you don't. If you don't get high
a lot, if you don't smoke a lot of pot,
you really shouldn't be fucking around
with those edibles. I'm just a boozer,
especially around like 100,000
people with cigarettes.
I think that's exactly very tricky.
It's very tricky.
Well, you know, you learn
your lesson and yeah,
I consider myself humbled by my
experiences at this past 2000 years and
12 Coachella. I've said this a
hundred times on the podcast,
but just in the interest of information,
when you eat it,
it's a totally different thing.
When you eat marijuana,
it's processed by your liver and it
produces something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite. This is like four to
five times more psychoactive den THC.
So that's what's going on.
So when you take it and you're like,
you don't feel high, you
feel like, like you're gone.
I felt like I was hallucinating.
I really did. Well it is, it is.
It looks like a dog. Shit was
happening. I was floating. Well,
if you closed your eyes too, you would
see amazing things behind your eyelids.
I mean, you see, um, I, I've, I've taken
in Gunton on planes before and you,
you have these, these shows where
it'll do this show under your eyelids.
Like you close your eyes and you
watched like neon cartoon things,
fuck each other and it's incredible.
Super Potent Shit. And it's, you know,
it's not the same thing as the smoking it.
It's a totally different experience and
it's not something you should just play
around with.
That's why those,
do you remember that I'm thing where the
cops stole some pot from some kids they
stole like in that pot round. No,
no real, it wasn't in the movie.
Super troopers in a real life situation.
When they called nine one one they
thought they were dying. Yeah.
They thought they had been poisoned.
They thought they were dying.
They thought they might be already dead.
Wait, I'm sorry. The cops, the cops did.
The cops took these kids.
We'd,
and then they ate it and then
they called nine one one.
The cops actually called nine one one
because they thought they were dying.
They were, they were freaking
out so bad. They look,
you got to call nine one one call them.
I'll call fuck it. I'm going to call.
It was just regular. No, they thought
they were poison or something. Brownies.
But I mean, do they eat them
because they're like, oh,
those look tasty. No, they,
they were,
they stole the kids pot and made pot
brownies and these fucking dummies didn't
know how to handle it.
They didn't know how to like,
didn't know what the dosage was. So then
they freak out and then they'd call it,
they call nine one one and they have to
fucking explain where they got all the
weed from. And what
happened. You crazy assholes.
They thought they were dead and you
can't get that high. You can get,
apparently eating hash is like the
nuttiest thing ever. And there's,
there's like ancient texts of like these
incredible psychedelic experience that
people experienced while they
were eating Hash, you know?
And so it was like who the, the of
a lot of their, you know, the I,
the idea of a, about the mystical
world, you know, was based on this,
this consumption of hash and
these crazy wild fucking trips.
They would go on these, it's
really similar to mushrooms,
animals when you hit,
when you eat a lot. Yeah. It gets
really similar. When you eat a lot,
it gets really similar, gets
it, gets really self examine
a Tori, you know, it's,
it's like great for clearing out
psychic baggage and you know,
exposing parts of your brain,
like think like people call it
insecure or they call it paranoid,
but really it's probably just
being aware, you know? I mean do,
you should kind of be freaking
out a little bit. You know,
we live in a crazy world.
It's kind of like after you have like
a really good cry and then after that
you're totally like, everything's cool.
You can handle whatever cause you're just,
he got it all out, you know, you're
too exhausted to bullshit. Yeah.
So you just have to be at,
at your truth.
Whoa. Yeah. Yeah. Dude. You know,
some of your best ideas come
when you're fucking exhausted.
Maybe that's what's good about how we
feel right now, Ben, because we're,
I feel like I,
I might spontaneously combust sometimes.
Yep.
Fucking businessman. Yeah. You guys
are super talented in a tough business.
You're in a weird spot. Thank you.
If you came along. No you are,
you're in a weird spot because if you
guys had come along like just a decade
earlier, it would have been a
real simple path to record sales.
A little bit of simple path to,
you know,
your own personal financial independence
just based on your art maybe, you know,
it's tough. I everyone is it like
there was some easy time. It never was.
I don't know if there was,
you know,
but I'm saying what I'm saying is that
at least you could sell records then.
Yeah, that's true. You can't sell
records anymore. You can, but the, the,
the amount that it's been
chewed down because of a,
I mean it's probably pretty
good with iTunes, you know,
but it's no where near what it used to
be. Not even close. What is the debt,
the damage,
like how much has the music industry
record sales and stuff you think been
damaged by the Internet?
Well,
I mean cds at basically killed cds and
that's what most of the structure has
been based around, you know,
all these distribution methods.
All these companies have built
themselves up around physical products,
but that doesn't really exist.
Right.
So now they're trying to adjust to these
digital sales methods and there isn't
like the framework,
right? So they have to invent it
on the fly and some companies fail
or they just do, they have to listen
to what iTunes tells him, you know?
Whereas before they were
kind of making up the rules.
Wow. That's crazy. How quickly it changed,
isn't it? You should talk about that.
Spotify thing was perfect. Oh
yeah, I heard they screw people.
What I heard Spotify has
been screwing artists.
Oh hell yeah. We've
got 9,400 on our, what?
We got another 300 out of five on our,
sometimes somebody told me,
somebody told me recently that Spotify
doesn't pay the artist for sure.
Don't barely at all at all. It's like
pennies on the dollar. And that's like
most internet things because it's trying
to figure out how you could possibly
offer this huge library of stuff to
somebody for like 10 bucks a month.
You know? Cause that's what people want to
pay. Right. Well, how could they do that?
Right. The idea is like that
that becomes like a, like a,
like a free trade radio sort of a
situation. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Hmm.
But I mean, here's the thing, it's like
I don't, I don't feel like, um, uh,
agro were malicious or angry towards
that mentality because, you know,
as long as people are listening,
that's great. Right. You know, but, um,
we're alive band at the core.
So when we're touring is when we're,
we're actually generating some sort of
income, which is great. Um, and you know,
but at this point it's like you have to
find these clever ways to try and make a
living. And I don't think
we're, I don't think we're far,
but like the reason we're doing this
Kickstarter account is cause we just want
that like that,
just a little bit of a leg up so we can
support the people that are around us
that are working very hard. You know,
it almost just as hard as we are and,
and then, you know, keep, keep the sort
of windfall ball rolling, you know,
that that can, you know, get to that place
where you're really sustained, you know,
and you're really, you're
really going. And um, you know,
at the end of the day we were talking
about how hard it is here and there and
like we're,
we're tired and um,
but like we made this choice
and we know that and I'm,
I wouldn't do anything else, you know,
unless I, if I'm doing this for 10 years,
but I don't, I don't think that's
going to happen, you know, hopefully.
But um,
you know,
you don't think what exactly
is going to happen in 10 years.
I'll have to find another job. You don't
ever have to find another job. Right.
I mean, isn't it all just about
more people seeing your stuff,
more people hearing your stuff. It's never
really about finding another job. Yeah.
You guys are slow build man. Yeah.
That's what it, it's a slow bill. That's,
I think that was the point.
I kind of don't ever really talk about,
you don't ever really think about
stopping this and finding another job.
Do you know it's all fucking
cry? No. Don't you cry Joe Rogan.
Derrick, have you guys thought, but
is it frustrating? Is that, yeah.
Yeah. I mean we're,
we're both, um, you know,
crashing with friends and stuff
like that. Like we, but that's okay.
Like that's part of being a musician.
It's like you don't get rich, you know,
quickly and you don't,
you know,
sometimes you never get rich and that
it's not about getting rich. We're,
we're trying to do what we love for a
living and, um, it's hard right now,
but, and you need a lot of
help from your friends. Like
in this day and age, artists make
the majority of their money touring.
So majority, either that or there's like
publishing channels, it's still exist.
If you get your stuff on a TV show TV,
there's actual money there.
But that's such a tiny
window, you know? So,
and what we're trying to do is just get
to a point where we can have the people
who support us really. Um, get to a
point where we can support ourselves.
You know what I mean? So it's a
really interesting concept. The uh,
the idea of like forming little
communities like that on the Internet,
you know, cause you know,
you're really, you're going to,
you reaching out to the people that
really enjoy your stuff and they want to
hear more of your stuff. Like you can
go right to them. Yeah. It's just you,
your voice, your little Kickstarter video,
right to them. No filter, no nothing.
Yeah, that was fun. So it was, it was,
have you really tested this patient?
What are you trying to do here?
In the end, it was really funny.
I really came together well, but
I was like, you guys are you guys,
you're on drugs not telling me the truth.
Oh,
that's amazing. I want to sit in
front of a camera and be like,
this is what we want to do.
Right. Well, you know, you guys,
you guys are silly, but it's
good to be solid. You know,
keep too many people are trying
too hard to be cool. You know,
you're way better off being silly.
Substitute Chili's fun so he's fun.
Serious is annoying.
That was a important moment.
I think when we realized as Joe was
watching it, it's like, oh wait,
we made a movie with a dunk.
Feels
like what the fuck is with the lipstick
on the cheeks and it's a rooster.
Are you guys doing your chicken
Brewster thing? Hey Brian,
we're never going to
put oil on that door. You know why?
Because people are complaining about it.
Are they really a myth? So can you
please put some Debbie d 40 on that door.
It's a fucking door man.
Do you trip?
And we are in your house and you have a
conversation and somebody opens up the
door. Do you trip? Do you go, what the
fuck mom? Grow Up. You little baby.
So the door squeaks.
Who Cares?
So many people can be so negative
assholes experiencing a lot of love on the
road though I got up,
I saw a lot of positive tweets
about people they went to see you.
I saw a lot of that.
We've got so much Rogan love, honestly,
like every single place we went and that,
this is no joke. It's like
there'd be at least if there were,
if it was a small night, there'd be like
five or 10 people that came from this,
but like in every city,
awesome. 40 to 50% of fans from,
from you, which was really cool.
Cincinnati, it was a huge, yeah.
That's so awesome to hear
those Ohio people are great.
The fan base in Ohio is huge.
That's why we need to go back
to [inaudible] after the show.
They need to go to Cleveland
to, yeah, it's a good town.
I did Cleveland with Charlie
Murphy. Oh, nice venue.
I forget.
It was one of the comedy
clubs. It was, um, man, I don't
remember which one it was.
It might've been the Improv if
there's an Improv there, right? No,
it was the hilarity. It's or something.
I don't remember. Sorry. I did a,
I did a tour with Charlie Murphy
and we did like 22 cities.
Yeah. And it was a month.
So it was like constant. You
never knew where you were. So
that's crazy. Yeah. I did
grog shop with Joey is,
what is that? It's grog shop. That's
where me and Joey Diaz went uh,
last month or two ago or whatever.
That's
the club you went? Yeah. And is that
Columbus or Cleveland? I was in Cleveland,
but yeah. So you guys went to like
a rock club or something like that?
It was like a, I think they do
both, but I think it's mostly music.
But it was cool. It was a nice
little place. Next set up dude.
I penises on the walls every time we
played there and my family's there.
I'm just Kinda like Ah, cause he's turning
penis isn't that? It's great. Yeah.
And yeah, it's like, it used to be a
real grunge kind of punk bar, you know,
rock and let me get in there and we play.
Or like folk rock,
blues music and it's fine.
You make it work.
Did you ever run into like a stumbling
block where people didn't want to hear
that kind of music?
Do you ever in a situation where like
nobody knows who you are and you want to
go and do your stuff and for whatever
reason people like heckle or act
negatively.
We've been so lucky man.
I feel like we played in
all these situations where
we're completely different
that we've opened for a lot of headliners
that we don't sound anything like and
no one's ever really put us down and I've
got this arsenal of comebacks that I'm
ready for it to be like to throw out at
that one guy who's being a dick and I
can't use them. Guess where you
guys, it's pretty nice to you guys.
You guys are creepy. I'm not inviting
anyone to be a jerk. Please love us.
You guys are creepy talented. You
guys are really good. You guys are,
you know when we went to see you
live I was like, this is like,
it's crazy that you can watch someone
like that close, like singing,
like it's such a different
experience when you're in a club.
I guess it's probably the same as
a, as a comic too. Like when you're,
you're in front of like a tight group of
a few hundred people just jammed into a
place that really is like the best
scenario, like the best kind of show.
It was so powerful. It was
like, wow, this is wild.
I am fascinated by music cause I
can't do it at all. So I'm like,
I'm watching you guys do magic.
You're putting together songs and you're
playing instruments to me. I'm like,
you're, you're doing magic. Like I can't
do that. I can't do anything with it.
So it's uh, it's amazing. It's so
fascinating. It's a, it's really
just to throw it back, it's like we
have a set list and we have this like,
you know,
rarely do you have to go off book,
quote unquote like every once in a while
you get a heckler. But we like people,
we like to hang, you know what's fine
hackleback and then you do your thing.
But like, you know, with comedy,
I feel like when you get,
you also have a sort of set list,
you know,
so to speak or your material
that you have planned.
But the off the cuff kind of stuff and
it's kind of terrifying because you can't
have a low in your comedic set like you
can when you're tuning your guitar in a
musical set. Yeah. Nobody wants to win
while you get your shit together. Exactly.
Don't
exactly what the joke there.
They need to be stimulated like
almost to the second. Yeah.
But it's still way easier then when
you guys do, I don't have to work this
video because you have,
I'm pretty sure there's a Joe Rogan and
Brian Redman is for parents in there.
It was great. It turned
out so great. Thank you.
We're so excited and it was awesome.
Really Weird. Sing a lot of it.
Yeah. And then seeing them because I think
we need to see their scene. Oh, you did.
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah,
so it was really cool to see like if
these people that I talk to all day,
not to be totally graphic, but he
said, I'm going to, I'm going to come.
Doesn't that, that's what he said.
He did that on purpose. He was like,
I'm just going to explore what they're
good for.
You Martin. And then the pastor dude
was really cool. Yeah, I guess he,
he just does it like, oh, there's
a Jason Ritter who was awesome.
Do you hang out with him that day?
He's a sweet dude.
Why did you kill him? I don't know.
Because he, he, he wasn't, uh,
he didn't love me enough. That was
funny when he did the zipper part.
That was, that was perfect, man.
He thought he was going to get
some and then that's how bitches,
oh, so you've been getting
a lot of road booty.
I mean, are you a, do you have a lot of
guy fans that are right at the point?
Brian?
Brian,
let's talk about your girlfriends and
then I'll talk about my boyfriends. No,
don't talk about his girl.
It's not clearly one of them had a tail.
Like a literal tails. No,
no, no. Please, please.
Just kidding.
I'm sure they're beautiful and
lovely and very smart. I, uh,
I'm single. Are you really? Yeah.
Shizam son.
That was a message.
Sure. Well, what do you do?
Radio Kurt? Green Light.
Do you want to hang out with queen honey?
Yes, I do. [inaudible] rumble, honey,
honey and Jack. Then just six kids to pass
the bottle and the ice. Let's get shit.
Oh my God. How many days
when you guys go on the road,
how many days do you go for like what's a,
what's a long two months?
As long as we've got two months.
I think
we did a couple of those, but yeah, man,
it's been like for the
past year and a half,
we haven't taken more than like three,
four maybe we've taken four
weeks off at one point.
But since then it's just been
constant, which has been, I mean it's,
it's amazing like she said, but
it's disorienting too, you know?
Well, so fascinating because you guys are
so talented and you know, it's, I'm, I'm,
I'm getting to watch like this
whole, uh, emergence of you. Like,
you know,
you're going on this tour,
getting all your shit on the internet
and it's growing. It's, it's,
it's fascinating to
watch. It really is. Yeah.
Cool. Yeah. It's you cool to see.
Yeah, you can see numbers built.
That's the different, is kind of where it
used to be. Like when my space came out,
all of a sudden you had these numbers,
that's signs of things.
Right?
But you sure right and didn't it,
you guys do it by youtube is like your
youtube numbers, is that what it is? Um,
Facebook and Twitter, he's spoken Twitter,
you know, the, the angel of death video.
We're kind of waiting for this to
hit some sort of swing cause it's,
it really is such a great video.
And um, but essentially it is,
it is Twitter and
Facebook, but you know, um,
we're trying to try and make
as many videos as we can.
Farm animals still a death video
is still you guys on that roof.
That's how I found out
about you. This, this,
this dude on my message board named balls.
Yeah.
Yeah. Balls of steel. Where as
long as he's out there somewhere,
he was super psyched when we were
talking about him on the podcast.
He sent me a message. Um, Gosh, well yeah,
that one where you guys were on the roof.
That is a fucking, I love
that one. That's my favorite.
That was like, this is so interesting.
This guy sent me a message. He goes,
this is your new favorite
band. Wow, man. What a guy.
We're going to find you balls of steel.
How Bob Dylan do you look
right there and son, you look,
you look mad. Bob Dylan, their kid
right there. I got hugs. Yeah,
that's it. I'm done. Oh Man. Sorry.
I remember that.
Yeah,
no, no. Now we're now that we're
buddies, you know, the first time,
you know when we found out
that you liked art music,
we had this weird day where
all of a sudden I was like,
I didn't really know how to use Twitter.
And actually because of of y'all,
we kind of really hopped on board to,
you know,
really work in the Twitter circuit.
But all of a sudden our Twitter
accounts kind of going crazy.
And then someone's like, Joe Rogan
tweeted at you. I was like, really?
I was like the guy from Mexico.
Sure. That's awesome. And,
and then I, I really did my
research, my research and I,
I listened to your podcast that you did.
And it was so funny because it was like,
he said the nicest things and is,
it was so flattering.
And he said, you know,
listen to this girl's
voice and you're just like,
God talking about these really
beautiful things. And then you're like,
do Rogan experience
sponsored by the flesh.
Right. I was like, I was amazing.
It was so cool because this was our
first podcast we've ever done. And,
and since then we've done a couple
more, which has been really cool. Um,
but you're,
you're a podcast champion.
You guys cool. You did. Dunkin's Oh my
God. Don't give them, wasn't in the shit.
Yeah. And he's become one of our friends
too, and he's special. We love him.
I love the fuck out of that dude. Him
and Brian are feuding though. Oh No,
I love the fuck out here. The roof. Oh,
I love the fuck out of both of them
separately. I have two right now.
Nobody's taken sides. Will get in
the middle of that. No, no, no, no.
Split of the rift. Please. You hear like,
you're either like shitty things are you
like, hey, how dare you? How dare you. How
dare you? Oh, apparently I like
both. I don't know who is who
should. We have an intervention
now, so that'll be, that'll be fine.
It's really minor detail. I'm only
reminded of it when Joe brings it up.
I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to,
I just had to because we were talking
about how awesome Dunkin as I feel like I
have to staff to say we can't talk too
nice about him because Brian and hammer
feuding sort of metaphysical way.
They're going to get over it eventually.
We're going to do ecstasy together and
then they'll be fine. They'll hug it out.
I'll pass that.
So weird sandwich
blacked out. I don't even know
what like whip cream and hot sauce.
I don't know if you know what
you want to put those together.
That sounds like you could
get an infection of cream
and hot sauce and I told
her you shouldn't put get
something chocolate up there.
No, you shouldn't keep it natural. No,
I have had friends who have done,
I think shit gets really messed up from
like from like beauty magazines like
cosmo. It's like, how to
please your man, you know,
with all this bullshit of like skirting
from what just feels right and you know,
being in a relationship or not,
or just being sexually confident,
but like,
you know people that bust out the
food part and then rub it on things.
You gotta be careful with that.
I don't know. Oh, like with sex,
if I was getting on some
dude and he's like, hold on,
I'm going to put some
whipped cream on her twinkle.
Zam it sounds like really uncomfortable
and stickies try it looks a problem.
It would just cause problems. You know
what I mean? Maybe not though. Maybe.
Awesome.
Want to just give me a massage,
but better yet. Let's just, let's just
go to chick fil a and call it a day. Wow.
It's either that or the highway. I guess
you've made your, you stay in your claim.
They'll cream.
Put Food on my special place.
Yeah. No, no, no
chick-fil-a, no food at all.
She's baked. That's the, that's the
abandonment movies. Go to chick fil a.
Let's forget the whole
thing. This is plan B. Now.
Maybe I'm just a traditional girl.
I just like to get down the regular
way without food. I agree with you.
No need to bring in cherries.
Mickey Rourke.
You remember that movie? Was it? And
what was it? Nine and a half weeks.
What was the movie with Mickey Rourke
and Kim? Basically one and a half weeks.
Is that what it was one of the first
movies ever master. Okay. Am I that?
I know the name of that.
Um, pretty good. Um, yeah,
it was a,
it's like a real sexual movie and they
did a lot of like food stuff and there
was like some when Kim based
your Wa oh it's hot as fuck.
She was so hot back then.
It was stupid. And you know,
and when her and man one works well,
he's
like kissing her and their,
he's feeding her grapes and shit.
Or after he reconstructed
his face way before. Well he,
you know what happened with him? He
started a box. That's right. My bad.
I stand corrected. Well, no, he
did have some like face work done,
but I think some of it really,
some of it was a little bit of
reconstructive stuff. He got, he got like,
he had like real problems apparently.
I read in some interview with
his get like neurological tests,
like the chats on them. They was like,
you have to stop boxing like you're,
you're having like brain issues.
So he had to stop.
But I mean the guy went from crazy,
went from being a fucking huge movie
star to being a boxer to back to being a
movie star yet.
Like that's a weird bond and
professionally and fighting the deal guys.
He was a boxing real people.
I mean they weren't,
they didn't set them up with like
some of the best guys in the world,
but they set them up with some good
fighters. Like he fought some boxers.
That's another backup of honey.
Honey doesn't work out.
It's either the brothel in Nevada
or boxing. People are always like,
because foot soak like Wilson, he's a
fucking actor. He's a goddamn movie star.
He fought real people. It was a
real food. You also wanted a box.
It's not like he's out there fighting
sugar ray Leonard or something. Okay.
It's like what a crazy Guy Mickey
Rourke was. That's a wild ass mood.
Did he win any bounce or
anything? Yeah. Yeah I did.
Well I think you won so many law.
I don't really remember his record.
I mean I remember watching him box wants
them so it was a real fight. You know,
he's really fucking boxing.
Some guy went from being a movie
star to being a fucking boxer.
He's getting punched in the face and
shit. You little whoa. This is legit.
I mean again, it wasn't fighting. The best
guys they do really was fighting. Yeah.
He must have been like a
heavyweight. Yeah, I met him
at a, one of the UFC. He's a,
he's probably a pretty big guy. He looks
like he's in really good shape. He got,
he got really big for that.
Um, that wrestler movie. He
did. Remember that movie?
What do you guys got in there?
They are looking for getting crazy.
I'm feeling a little warm. Do you
want a water? I'm good. I'm good.
I'm sticking with my eco vessel.
What does that well too to sort of
reduce on the plastic pollution.
Right, but it's got a little
filter in it and we take,
I take it on the road with me so I could
drink river water out of this thing.
I know I'm,
wow.
I think we're going to go full circle
and then we'll come back to deer skins.
I'm down. You going to be glad. When I
get my food with a bow and Arrow ladder,
I watched those shows. I watch those
shows on like the outdoorsman channel.
It's a shoot pigs of the
bone deadwood. It's like this
is, that's, that's where we,
that's those are our ancestors. Well,
it's weird when you shit went down.
That was how everybody had to live
just a couple of hundred years ago.
There's no other options. This is what,
this is the way it was. That's it.
Go out and kill animals. Have
you ever gone hunting Joe?
No. I'm going soon though.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I used
to go fishing a lot.
What type of delicate form of going
hunting for deer. Really check this out.
This is kind of fucked up.
Uh, Los Angeles just banned
all marijuana dispensaries.
Shit.
So true. How did they just posted
this? How has that Po, is that, wait,
where are you reading that?
It says the Los Angeles City Council.
It has just voted to ban all
medical marijuana dispensaries.
Council member Paul Cortez was the
only person to vote against the ban.
Um,
this exemptions will allow patients to
continue growing marijuana for their own
use and primary caregivers may
continue to distribute the drug.
So don't worry about the cancer patients.
They'll be fine as cities,
physicians to find a dealer.
Um, so this is just within
the city of Los Angeles. I,
I'm not 100% sure right now,
but that's Kinda Kinda fucked.
That's pretty crazy.
I wonder if like that, like the, the, the,
the people that like la speed
weed that aren't a dispensary,
but they can deliver it. It's pointless.
Like why, why, why, why is this happening?
You know, it's like, give me
the logic, show me the numbers.
Show me where somebody is getting hurt.
Why are any resources being
spent in this way so, so silly?
Well, I wonder if, um, that's so cray one,
is there much government regulation
on the dispensary's because you know,
as far as like taxation purposes like
isn't, I mean California is broke.
They could certainly use the money.
Perhaps they want to come back with
their own spin on things. That's,
I don't think that's what's
going on. I think, uh, it's,
it's one business pushing on
another business. There's no,
there's no logical reason for them to
be trying to go after these people.
It doesn't make any sense. It's not
like you're trying to protect society,
excuse me, protect society from
marijuana. I mean there's no,
there's no science or numbers to back
that up. It doesn't make any sense.
Especially while you're selling liquor
at the liquor store and the drugs at cvs,
it's like to say that you're going to
spend any resources to stop marijuana at
all those, it's crazy. It's like I
don't care if that's been there already.
You're showing me something that exists
right now and then in a liquor store
that's far more dangerous than some
marijuana, and you're saying that's okay.
Fuck yet is more dangerous to your body.
More destructive,
more dangerous for social behavior,
more dangerous for driving,
more dangerous for almost the buzz right
now. Don't ruin this for me. I like,
I'd like booze,
but it's just we,
it's nonsense that we would allow
them to use any resources to stop pot.
It doesn't make any sense.
There's no reason why you would go after
that when you haven't fixed all the
streets. You haven't solved
all the murders. You haven't
stopped all the crimes.
He, why are you raising wasting
any resources on this silly issue?
This is dumb. We're going to
get an interest that have money.
Tennessee honey. Oh my goodness. What
is that? What did you just put down?
Is that Jack Daniels? Jack Daniels.
Honey, I think we have chips here,
but that'll sound awesome
on the microphone. Great.
I guess is how we make
friends on the Internet.
Whoa. What's she? Oh Damn. What
is, what is that name again? Test.
Is it a Burrito?
The rice and you go,
I want to eat that and then saying or
you want us to say? Probably same first.
I should probably say how the recipe
you'll be spraying all over this mother
fucker. What a lady. Um, I'm supposed
to have dinner with my parents.
Actually my parents are in town.
They came out to see us for Sheryl Crow,
which is really, really cool. Awesome.
Yeah, they're, they're fine. So, uh,
you've been living in this crazy little
dream life now. Does it feel like it? Um,
it's, uh, it's interesting, you know,
like right now I'm like, I'm
really tired, really working hard.
Like you're constantly drawing,
constantly performing.
I'm at that point where I'm just like,
fuck,
like I just want a little bit
of slack something. Right. Um,
and I think we're close,
you know,
I think this Kickstarter things
going to help us a lot. Um,
and Sheryl crow has been amazing.
And um,
actually Ben and I need to finish writing
our third record and we're going to
actually spend some time in Nashville,
which is a very reasonable,
reasonably priced place to live.
I've been drinking,
but it's a, it's a nice area.
Nashville, it's beautiful. It's great.
You know what it has, it has all this
space. And now I've got Louise, the dog,
Ralphie may lives in Nashville. Do
you know Ralphie's comedian? I don't.
He shares that. He's got a house there
in a house here. I thought, oh cool,
we should talk to him. We're doing some
shows there and stuff like that. But um,
you know, everything's been
great. I, at the end of the day,
I'll be honest with you that,
you know,
because all these like
uncomfortable places we're in,
because I'll to speak candidly,
Ben and I are without places
of our own right to live.
So we like crashed with friends and
that gets hard after a while because you
just feel like an asshole all the time.
But it's so old school rock and roll. No.
Well, yes and no, but, but you know, I am.
Yes. You need that chapter in the movie.
You're right. You're
absolutely right. Um, and I,
I do have appreciation for it and
I, I feel really good, you know,
even when I'm tired and all that stuff.
But the coolest part is that I,
I feel really good about the tunes
are writing and, and just the,
the shows we've been
playing because there,
there is this like element of like
that's like the place where I am the
happiest.
Do you know what I mean?
Like to be right now as far as this is
when you're creative, why don't we, yeah.
When I'm, when we're playing, you know,
when we're on the stage, cause it's like,
it's this great experience and
there's a lot of things happening, um,
up there that like make
it, it's like, oh yeah,
that's why we're sleeping on couches. It
amazing. That was really good. You know,
your life narrowed down to such a
focus, you know what I mean? Right.
Because everything is going into this,
these like this 45 minutes every day
on stage were out for two months,
for 45 minutes, you know, like
five times a week. So it'd be,
it becomes this like focal point of
everything, which is like, I don't know,
that's an exciting feeling I guess.
Oh yeah. Yeah. I share
it with a standup comedy.
It's a very similar sort of a intense
moment that you prepare for all the time.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah. It's, it's so, so weird.
Things performing. You know,
I've always just tried to describe it,
like,
just be step outside of civilization
and look at what's really going on.
What is really going on when you're
performing well at some weird energy
exchange. It's like you're, you're giving
them these things that you thought up,
this creativity that you've worked on and
honed and you're showing them this and
it's entertaining and they feel good.
They feel good when they listen
to your song, they feel good.
When you play a great
song and you hit a note,
literally the person's
body feels different. Yeah.
And that's what happens when
you do comedy as well. When you,
when someone's on stage and
they're killing, and I'm,
I'm watching it on my holding my sides
laughing. My body's feels different.
My body's like tingling with laughter.
Like if Joey Diaz,
she starts still even don't even know
Joey Diaz. You gotta meet Joey Dance.
I know the name. I know you guys
talk about him. Funniest human being.
I've ever met in my life. You'll
just, you'll be in the role.
He just to break things down for you
cock sucker. It'll just tell you he's,
he's just crazy old Cuban dude.
He's the baddest motherfucker ever.
But he makes me laugh so hard
that my body feels different.
Bodies like tingling, hilarity,
you know, that's, that's uh,
that's why we're so addicted to it.
We're so addicted to this weird
energy exchange, you know? No,
I really want to talk about this thing
that happened for our first Sheryl crow
show. You know, in relation to
what you're saying. And like, um,
we played in this theater in Santa Rosa,
California and it, it was sold out.
There's like about 1500
people and it was indoors. Um,
and a lot of times when you play theaters,
you know,
everybody sits for the opening band. So
there's, it's, it's kind of an awkward,
like, you feel like, oh fuck.
Like nobody's getting up when there's
like a more sort of upbeat song and you're
just like, it's quiet. You could
hear a pin drop, which is good,
but it's like totally nerve wracking.
But we had this thing,
this really great show. Um, and at
the, at the end of the show, um,
you know,
everybody,
and this was the second time this has
happened and we've been a band for a long
time and the second time we,
we felt this way in a theater and it was
sort of somebody else's show, you know,
were the opening band. It's not our show
there. They're there to see Sheryl crow.
Right? And we're fortunately, you know,
fortunate enough to be
there to get some attention.
And we had this incredible standing
ovation and they put the lights on the
people and you could see just this,
all these people like,
and they were glowing and it just like,
it was like this,
like it was like a wave crashing over you.
But like it like a good way of just
like people being like, yeah, all right,
we like you, we accept you. And it was so
intense that like my, I was, I, you know,
my, my eyes were kind of crying and I was
so embarrassed because I didn't want to
like look like an idiot,
but it was so like physically my body
was like accepting all this warmth from
all these strangers and it was, it
was amazing. It was so great. Yeah,
it's a trippy feeling. It really is.
A similar thing happened at Coachella.
I felt like there was people so excited to
be there at Coachella.
It's this crazy experience and then
you're in this place in the middle of the
desert and everyone's just so pumped
up to see whatever happens in the first
moment in our set where like a big beat
dropped. Like in the, the second song,
which is Gosh,
there was this like eruption from the
crowd and everyone just gave you this huge
burst of energy and I felt less
self, you know, you have to like
mom's breath for real. It's the
weirdest thing. When I was a kid,
I remember I would listen to like kiss
live and when you listen to a live album,
it was always like a little off.
They were like a little faster.
Like the song was like a little faster.
It's like something I'm not always,
but sometimes and I was like,
I wonder what that is.
Why it sounds well it's because they're
fucking jazzed up with adrenaline.
I mean, what, what's, what's
it been like to be kissed?
You imagine just standing on stage being
an ace freely in 1975 fireworks are
going off in your guitars.
It's the fucking places going Shit House.
28,000 people screaming at the top of
their lungs and they're painted. Yeah,
I mean we should start painting your
face. I was a kid during the, the,
the first big wave of,
of kiss and then I,
I couldn't imagine what it would be
like to play music like that in front of
that many people. Of course
he'd be playing a fast. Yeah,
that was a fanatical following the kiss
army. I still have a kiss army tee shirt.
Oh, it's a, it's a weird thing
playing for a large volume of people.
Most of you guys have played
for 10,000 people. We were in,
we were in Chicago. This is a duo to,
as a duo, is it just the two of us?
And actually at one point within our set,
the power went out in the
middle of a song and it's like,
that would be like, Oh God, I just peed
myself on stage and everyone can see it.
Well then you just go step that.
No,
it's way better though to do that
then the P or cell phones too. Right?
You're absolutely right. You're totally
right yourself on stage. Just like, dude,
you're fucking,
you are on your own now.
Nobody wants to hear
anything you have to say now.
No one's going to take any of these days.
Seriously.
He just pissed your parents dude. And
it's so rude. Really, because we bought,
knocks the wind out of you, you know, to
be in front all those people. But anyway,
not to get off of the stage pants paying
thing cause that's fun. But, um, yeah,
that was the most we'd ever played for
and that was a real people. Holy Shit.
That's a lot of people.
Whew.
For sure.
We're opening for Sheryl Crow.
This is the thing called the
Chicago folk roots festival.
This is just this festival we played a
couple of summers ago and there's just
this huge field and we'd get up there.
It's just the two of us kind of thing.
That's beautiful man.
Yeah. Oh cool. Is that,
that must be such a trip.
What does that feel like?
Well, when you get the energy back, when
there's this surge of anyone telling you,
it's just like,
I felt it all through my body and I had
to like slow down literally within the
song from just like,
oop. You know? You know what though?
I see myself with that energy.
It's like you have this incredible
experience, um, when you're, you know,
you're in point a and the audiences in
point B and then you kind of have to like,
you have to leave it there once you leave
the stage because if you take all that
energy with you,
like that's how you want to go,
like stick a needle in your arm
sometimes or like do something crazy.
Like I'd be like,
I feel like that energy is his not mine.
You know what I mean?
Like I have to leave it on the stage.
I really appreciate it when I'm there,
but I had this, I had a real moment of,
of revelation, um, from one of
our first or second tours I can,
I'm getting a little crazy, but
I, I met like, I had like my,
my palm read this, like this woman told
me that she's like, you, you need to,
you need to protect yourself and when
you leave the stage you need to leave the
stage and then have yourself as a separate
entity because otherwise it'll like
swallow you up.
And I believe that to be true.
I think that if I were to take all the
attention that I got on the stage as a
personal definition, I
think that's, that's a,
that's troublesome for my person
because I, you know, I'm there if I,
if I just live my life, like I
do my job and I have, you know,
my musical abilities and gifts and that's,
that's one thing.
And then that's my job and then my
passion and then then these other parts of
myself, like my family and my
friends and my dog and my new dog.
So I know what you're saying. Like,
look, that's just very apartment.
Ally's it's very wise to try to
separate yourself and hence your ego.
Yeah.
Cause it's dangerous.
It can be come self indulgent and
that's what everyone's terrified of.
Everyone's terrified of becoming
that a really ridiculous,
like a overbearing star singer person.
You know what I mean?
Like someone is just completely
out of control. A diva,
someone's screaming and yelling at people,
someone who's nuts.
It doesn't appreciate like every,
every minute of the ride. Right.
You realize how fortunate they are.
I mean that's,
that's what any artist is
terrified it becoming that person,
that disillusioned dis
dis disconnected person.
That's the worst thing that could
be, you know, you cannot be creative.
People who are in that position have,
it's, it's not, uh, out of maliciousness.
Is that a lack of awareness?
You just losing touch. It's,
it's been really great to see Sheryl Crow
because she is truly an amazing woman
and, and is humbled and so successful
yet so grounded. And she's got,
she's got her kids with her on the road
and the like this incredible crew around
her of people that they've been
helping us, which is, you know,
sometimes it's the opening band. You're
not, you're, you're the freshmen,
so no one's gonna like help the freshmen.
But, but that's a great example.
You know what I mean?
It's like a bitch with all due
respect to totally respectful.
But it is, it is, as you
said, you know, your ego can,
could just be like this atom bomb within
such a great thing and you don't want
that.
That's how the avoid that when you,
I really firmly believe that when
you get really crazy like that,
it hinders you creativity.
It's like you're not gonna have anything
else to say.
You're not going to have any other places
to go to because you're in like some
words sort of a psychic prison.
I know you'd trapped herself in this
weird world of not looking at things
realistically or I or idealistically,
you've trapped yourself in this world
of negative, you know, in your, your,
your country
and the universe doesn't like tough
love that word. Beautiful Man.
I'm so glad we didn't make a drinking
game out of it cause I'd be more drunk
than I already am and I'm really thinking
about it. I'm pretty hamster right now.
You know,
I got this one
writing program that I use on my
computer and it won't learn con
awesome.
You can make up a word you get.
It'll learn everything else and learn
shadow. Correct. Every learn. Fuck it.
It gets to con want go for the
right click and it's like, nope,
I won't even let you fucking,
I'm like you little bitch.
But it'll let you add conti. Ah, Jesus,
this is good.
This pot thing is freaking me out.
764 tax stream revenue
streams are just being cut.
Here's the news. If you want to look at
what happens, here's The p after you.
That's how it grows. Like medical
marijuana license dog shit, go on.
Welcome back. The medical
marijuana is legal in California,
but some say the dispensary's bring crime
and a nuisance to their neighborhoods.
Let's go live to Doug coke in
downtown La were boisterous,
appalled with these robots.
Supporters of the bad robot.
People that robot ladies go to
the robot guy who and Jessica has,
you know it's a very heated topic
and it doesn't look like a decision.
May come time and come down anytime soon.
City Council right now behind closed
doors in a closed session discussing the
legalities surrounding the possibility
of closing hundreds of medical marijuana
facilities around the Los Angeles.
We are out of control with it.
At this point.
We need to come up with something
that's going to work some of the police
department could live with the committee
can live with because we get continuing
complaints.
If only it were that easy.
City Council set to vote
Tuesday on whether to make
la pop dispensary's illegal
before members make that decision.
They hear public comment from both sides.
Those who depend on medicinal marijuana
for health is that tool shit pot
dispensaries or getting out of control.
It's even LAPD stance.
Pop clinics attract crime counsel trying
to find a solution for both the crime
as part whether that
means tighter enforcement,
limiting the number of dispensaries or
allowing a certain amount of caregivers
to grow marijuana under their
own conditions. Whatever
decision is made today,
it won't be made without heavy debate.
I believe in the medicinal
value of marijuana.
What we want to do is ban dispensaries
that are not allowed under state law.
I have friends that are still alive
today because of medical marijuana and
that's why this is so important to me.
Okay,
let's keep it down.
Pause down
now. Before they went into that
close, I had the chance to speak
with district five member Paul Koretz
and he tells me he has no clue, uh,
when a decision will come down today, if
in fact a decision does come down today,
he also tells me he has no clue which
way it's going to go. As matter of fact,
you've been telling me
it could end in a seven,
it's seven vote in which then they'll
have to figure out what's going to happen.
Reporting live from City Hall.
Doug Coke Ktlk five news.
Well unfortunately it did happen.
Fortina Oban Wow.
So I it really sucks
because I don't know if,
I wonder if you'll be able
to still deliver it cause if,
if you can get it delivered that,
that'd be different. If they,
if they just want to close it down to
have stores cause the neighborhoods and
crime, that's one thing. But if you
could have it delivered like pizza,
cause that's still, I believe legal. So
it would just ban a storefront. Yeah,
the store front. So I, I
believe like, you know, we, uh,
were friends with this company
called La speed weed, which you,
it's a delivery service and it's,
I think the Las largest one.
And I wonder if now if
that's the next thing,
like you're going to see these delivery
like pizza delivery trucks going down
the street everywhere,
making more traffic,
stoner traffic.
Uh,
it's kind of like what New
York is like, isn't it? Yeah.
I don't think there's much
more uh, delivery. Yeah.
Delivery based because they don't
have this master. Is that yeah.
Do that. They don't, they don't. They
don't. I think so. I'm wondering, well,
if it's just la county like it,
that means I wonder if that means
if the valley, like, you know, like
these people aren't even potheads Brian,
they don't care.
Look at the both of them. They
don't care. They get go dispensary.
You wouldn't even panic. No Way. If
someone said no more whiskey for you,
I'd be like, Ha, I dead body. But
that's not what they're saying.
They're saying no more pie.
Like, I'm cool with that.
Like I already went down a
dark road once accidentally,
Daniels distillery and stuck
up for the rest of eternity.
I don't know what to do with that pot.
Especially for writing.
I really don't know what I do. You be
real productive. Favorite Shit. Yeah.
Well can we? Yeah, I'm super
productive. See it's funny.
Everything affects everybody differently.
I bitch when I am high.
I bet it's the rock a bit. You get in the
wrong shit. I, you know, I don't know.
I've tried all the different
things the best. I think, you know,
vessel has been a spliff for me because
it's just a little bit and I like,
I like tobacco, like
cigarettes. So you know,
you could smoke a cigarette
if you want one. I'm good.
Actually I haven't smoked it a couple
of weeks cause when I'm touring I try to
fucking keep worrying. Worry about that
with your voice thing. Yeah, absolutely.
So I don't smoke like I used to,
but I,
when I do like I really fucking enjoy a
cigarette but I don't smoke all the time.
That's an Internet meme right there.
What you just said is going
to be an Internet meme. So me,
a photo of you saying I don't smoke,
but if I do it's going to be a cigarette.
Is that what I said? Oh, what a
winner. Oh Great. Don't encourage
you rarely smoke. Like I really
enjoy it when I do. It's like,
you know, cause like I'm a singer.
That's stupid. What I'm saying.
I mean you have that crazy gift. Well
thank you. But I mean, I, you know,
I used to smoke a lot and then I became
aware of how much of a hazard that was
to my,
my career,
my moneymaker pleasure you can produce
by making noise with your mouth.
Think about that. That's really, that's
what your career, not really, man.
My mouth is very important. Yeah, but
that's just the response. It's no, no,
no, no. You, when you do it,
it's totally different
because when you're singing,
it's a completely different experience.
The actual harmony of the words of the
sound you're making with your mouth.
Why don't harmonize with
themselves, whatever the fuck
it is. W the harmony of it.
Is it just about, am I saying
the right thing? Whatever it is,
the whole awesome miss of it.
Okay. I cranium with your mouth.
You're creating with your
mouth. That's amazing. You
know like when, when the, the,
the part of that video that I loved
when you guys were on the roof,
it was like just the first,
the first verse,
like when the first few words of
your mouth, he's like, he'd go, Whoa,
that's a crazy noise she can make
with our mouth. It sounds bad ass,
you know, because it's like I have
a weird laugh. Whatever it is,
it's, it's, it's the sound of
it and then it's more than that.
It's the idea expressed in the words
and then even crazier your energy and
interpretation. It could be whatever
fucking pent up shit you have.
It doesn't even have to have
anything to do with the lyrics,
but it goes through those lyrics
and comes out in the song.
And when someone sings with like
real emotion and real passion,
it's like a creepy feeling.
It's like you almost feel like you
shouldn't be allowed to be watching this.
It's like they really,
you really like,
especially you two guys on that rooftop
because or wherever the fuck you were
because there was a tap was a rooftop,
but because there was no one else,
it wasn't, it wasn't like it was a crowd.
It wasn't like there was, you know,
synthesizers are in it.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just you guys on the rooftop there.
So God damn sweet Joe.
I'm just being really nice and
we appreciate it. Well listen,
you guys are the shit. Play
some music. Can I a question?
I hope so. Can I request La
River? Fuck. Can't do it.
Give us a sec. You've got to have to,
can we start off with something else?
A warmer? Yeah, yeah, sure,
sure, sure, sure. I just love
that song. Oh, that's so funny.
I'm sorry. I should have a rude, I
forget. I'm an idiot. Like I told you,
I don't know anything about music.
I mean,
you would have to actually have
the right stuff and I'm like,
make the noise that make
that song sound so good.
Come on and make that
noise with your mouth.
Mechanical devices.
How do you know when on
when you're tuning it, you just know
about your hearing it we use machines,
these machines to tune things.
Was it old school and the old
school way? Was it? Um, was it,
I think they still buy electronic
tuners eighties. Oh really? Yeah.
And it,
and it changed things a lot man,
because all of a sudden you have this
precision. That's right. Which is good.
And also, I mean it's like
kind of analog to digital.
Who's your favorite guitarist ever? And
this guy named Django Reinhardt. Oh,
you're one of those obscure indie dude's.
I see what you're doing there. Also,
Jimi Hendrix. Awesome. I loved it.
That's why I named this teacher Rogan
experience. I totally jacked Jimmy. Jimmy,
I have no less than 15
Jimi Hendrix tee shirts.
Brian Bohm. Gary Gary Clark Jr. Yeah.
Why don't I know that name? Yeah, he's a
musician in New York. Uh, Austin. Austin.
You got to check him. Yeah, he's, he uh,
is a black gentleman and he says like
this bluesy rock. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Somebody recommended
him. I radically enough.
I don't think it's ironically but
recommended. Sorry. Sorry, please.
They recommended a him on
a thread about you guys,
which is even more fascinating.
And my message boards,
I think they brought it up last
time they were on the farm. Did you?
I don't remember.
That's what Brian's here.
God point mother fucker.
So he's um,
what does his, what does his, um, his,
his CD or as record or release
or whatever you would call it.
Not as digital release.
Is that what you call them?
What do you call them? Like when you guys
put d, Say, hey, we put out a new Erp,
recode. Recode. You still say yes,
they'll say record,
right? No fucking excuses.
Push House honey, honey.
And I'm from Cleveland.
I hope they can keep that whole
English accent thing going.
I hope the world in this
age of information and
distribution of information
doesn't match nice.
I hope they don't become Americanized.
Like send them too many
movies and break their will.
They'll just going to realize,
but it's a better way to talk.
The Americans have a better way to talk.
Let's be honest.
Fucking might just join them.
We'll just lead with the ego.
Lead with ego.
We're America and we're not content.
That's my a new logo for what everyone
in 2016 it's a we're America and we're
not convinced.
That's our philosophy.
So anything that we do as Americans
that would make us look like cuts we
automatically can't do.
Cause we've said we're not cutting.
So now he can't be starting any wars. If
you're, if you're not a client, you know
he can't be robbing anybody.
Can't be spying on you citizens
unless you're a should be.
We're America and we're not
tons. I like that 2016
that's going to make it work.
[inaudible] vice president
assassination proof. That's right.
Nobody wants to kill me.
Let Brian be president.
Get your helmets on.
Yeah,
right. We'll turn the White House
and into a mother fucking strip club.
Imagine if you could
like make Molly legal,
like if you became the even making
weed legal and you're just like,
I'm really bummed out Angeles too.
I can't believe that happened.
So is this a happy song?
You should really know Brian.
You're right. You should be bummed out.
It's really disgusting. It's disgusting.
I mean it's just,
it's nonsense.
What did we do here? It's not,
I would sort of happen recorded,
but this is called [inaudible].
[inaudible]. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
You want it? Okay. Hold on.
Ah,
no.
Bushmaster from it.
I can't take it
to make me change my mind.
Then you got to show me.
You Good Sam.
Ooh, you got on him? He get mad.
Oh,
ah.
Oh
wait.
I seen that door should deep in your,
when you always cut me down
on the kitchen.
Oh.
Is that how you get
ma'am?
Maybe.
I don't know of,
Oh,
Holy Shit.
You guys are awesome
string.
I might be the only one we can play.
Daddy's got some more history to my this.
That was amazing.
That was incredible.
That's the water. It's a great,
great, guys are so fucking talented.
It's stupid. Oh, you back? You
guys are really fucking good.
It's Kinda creepy. Kind
of creep me out, man.
I'm not sure like it is that how,
how did that song that you guys have,
that sucks. What was the name of that
song again? It's called numb. Numb it.
And what, how did that come
about? It came about from, um,
let's see. Um, probably
something to do about deck.
[inaudible] in a tough place
and you just don't want to,
if I can look the other way. He
liked our whiskey. Young lady.
Don't you know I do dare you.
Nothing.
Nothing at all.
It's a gift to the universe.
Just like your beloved devil's
lettuce.
Awesome.
It was marijuana like the whiskey too.
I think I'm to become an alcoholic
now that I can't go to the store.
We should all just start drinking
more. Yeah. Well that's what they want.
Yeah.
It's the whole thing is just so fucking
stupid that they're trying to suppress
it in any way, shape or form. That's
not to serve or protect. Cut Shit.
It's stupid. It's dumb. Making
no sense. Leave us alone.
Is that official?
I wasn't paying attention
laws. Too many laws set.
Don't need to have that many.
700 plus a dispensary is all at,
where did he just shut down immediately?
So fucking stupid. And
these, some of these places,
these are like mom and pop places.
Like I know there's one place and they
make their living like how the hell we're
getting suppressed, ladies and
gentlemen, the streets are going to fire.
You know what?
She should be filled with smoke.
Maybe six and beanbag.
Ooh,
I'm saying,
um, often. Do you guys want to,
I wanted to ask you earlier,
how often do you guys sit down
together and try to write like,
it seems like you're so hectic,
you're constantly going from town.
No, late lately it's been, um,
we probably have written once in
the past week, but you know, after,
after the Sheryl crow dates,
we were going to be on a schedule where
we're writing every day just to get the
next record out.
So
yeah, it's super hard for me if I'm
on the road just for like a weekend,
I couldn't imagine doing it for like five
and 600 constantly going from town to
town and they're trying to
squeeze in some writing.
It's got to be really hard to
put yourself in a place. I mean,
I don't know how you guys, right. How
do you, do you, um, do you have like a,
an idea first or do you jam,
do you, how do you guys, right.
Everything, we don't really have
look up, I'm chewing on ice cubes.
Oh, that's very cool. Like Carmen idea,
someone comes in with part
of the song and then if that,
so like art isn't good enough, you know,
for the other person to be excited,
then we just try to finish it.
So, um, you know,
like you'll like be driving in your car
or something and you'll just have an
idea and you write it down and put
it in your iPhone or something.
And then you guys,
every once in a while you'll
get this like whitening of the,
you'll write a whole song in
a day be like this, you know,
waterfall of words. And
they were like, fuck yeah.
And then sometimes you really got to
chip away at songs and some of our better
songs,
I feel like we've really been,
we've chipped away at and they've
started as one thing and then bend this
completely different, you know,
product by the end. Right.
You know that like the best part,
I mean not the best part but I just,
I guess you just have to like let it
be what it is and we try to be diligent
about it to write consistently. Even if
it sucks. It's like let's just do it.
You know, you have to exercise
this muscle. Um, but you know,
the more you do that,
the more you kind of get to that place.
You want to be out and writing with Ben,
we've been writing partners for years
now and never have any other writers.
We have, we have, but it's,
it's so different. It's like we,
he and I have the shorthand,
you know what I mean?
Like we of your stuff written by
Youtube. Yes. It's a very interesting
collaborative process cause you know,
you're both very unique and
yet you're both, you know,
very good and you got to figure out how
to do it together and like this weird
sort of a spiral that works
your ideas and his ideas.
And that's fascinating to me
cause like a lot of people,
they don't do it that way. Right. Like
one guy will be the one who writes it or
make the music or something. Yeah, you
guys do it all together. That's bad ass.
Yeah. That's a cool
relationship. You guys are like,
like almost like brothers and sisters,
like tied together for life, you know,
brothers and sisters on earth. In music.
We're a Siamese twins by the fingernail.
Yup. Something crazy. It
says John Hodge. Fascinating.
It's a fascinating relationship. You
know that you and and it works so well.
Your music is such, it's got, you
know, all the songs are different,
but you know when a song's
coming from someone, you know,
like there's certain like certain bands
you just knew when you heard like a
specific, unless you, okay.
Brian, what was that on my phone.
It's amazing what a beating and iPhone
case for tankers. Yeah. My, my phones
like tank Abbott in the early days
competing. Right. Um, you guys want
play something else? Sure. Can you,
can you play La River please?
If
I mess it up, don't get mad
at me. How dare you. You're
not going to mess this up.
Probably half a bottle of Jameson's.
And how dare you. Oh, there we go.
That's great.
Lead with a handicap.
Or You guys too, too drunk for the
Internet. Is there a such thing?
Nobody's watching right
over you. Don't worry about it.
Listen, I love you so bad, man.
You like a sister to be a man
down to the banks of the
concrete.
Oh.
Oh listen to the big CD sound.
Shane's path.
China town.
My fingers.
Wow.
Skin
sale.
Mabo down.
Oh,
I saw body.
Oh boy.
To the big city south.
Gotcha.
Matt.
All down trains pass.
Oh,
ah.
To the big
why
down by the chains pass Chinatown.
Ah,
man.
Yeah. Boy, that was a beautiful song.
That was a beautiful song. I love
that song. It's so creepy to, Oh,
you got skinned knees, you're looking
for bodies. The water's black.
There's a lot creepy shit.
Jumping fences. Los Angeles.
Fuck yeah, it is, but it's cool. You know,
I love the, I love new, my new home park.
It was on his TV, so really cool. Yeah,
it's called brothers and
sisters is on this. Okay.
And there's like this wedding weddings
and then these beautiful romance,
these people holding hands and then he
thought it's how body in the weeds coming
up. They just like, they
weren't listening to him. Well,
maybe they were trying to be ironic.
Maybe they were like fake hipsters.
It didn't really understand it,
so they're trying to use your
music in a fucking nefarious
way. Yeah, that's what it was.
That word in the Ferris wheel,
it's almost as good as a foot,
a foot like that. Serious.
You can use it in there. There may be
some fuckery of foot. That's a very,
also a good word is as good
as it gets. Yeah. I happened,
I stopped using that one and it was
restarted by my friend Steve Maxwell,
who was talking about like fake
martial arts guys. It's like, Hey,
there's a lot of fuckery involved. Oh, I
love this guy, but that's it. The word,
I fucking lost it for a long time.
Now it's back fine.
You can keep buying it with a foot.
You know something you could bring up
almost every day if something's wrong.
He's just saying, I believe there's
some fuckery afoot. Right? I like that.
The whole, the whole
thing better. How do we,
how do we move you guys to
the next level of, uh, of,
of showbusiness stardom,
whatever it is to get your shit out there
so you don't have all these financial
issues because this shit is annoying me.
Well, and it's annoying me that you guys
can be good and have any money problems.
We reach our Kickstarter goal.
That'll help a lot because it'll
get us through this next tour.
We're going out in October.
Let's be totally clear.
We're not just asking for money to
like sit here and play songs. We have,
we have a tour in October with a band
called trampled by turtles and they're
incredible. They're there.
This, uh, uh, their, uh, um,
a bluegrass band from
Duluth, Minnesota. And um,
in order for us to go out with them,
we need help.
We need financial assistance because
we were like, we're at zero. Right?
And it doesn't pay enough to
even pay for your expenses. No.
And to get the merchandise and all that
stuff and to pay for a tour manager and
a van and gas alone.
You know it's really fucking hard.
Yeah, it's, you're in a weird situation.
It's like you guys are like
superstar artists. You like
super talented, like your,
your music is amazing. But I'm like,
how the fuck are you bitches broke?
That doesn't make any sense.
Really irresponsible areas. Yeah.
Betty spends a lot of money
on mod products. Fuck fuck.
I love a nice pair of Chinos.
Open the sports page. Fuck.
He goes into j crew and he
spends thousands of dollars
do goes off on that.
But like I can and smelly bath
places at those at the ball.
Do I? Yeah. You know,
let's put together some people just
buy a bunch of shit I'll never use.
Oh a bad thought. I'm going to
take it. I'll be honest with you,
when I was younger and I had it,
like when I,
when I had a steady job actually when I
worked at Baby Blues Selling Barbecue,
I made more money selling barbecue
than I did with a record deal.
I had like sweet cash all the time and
I would just buy whatever I wanted.
Like I was like,
I'd go to nice restaurants all the
time with my friends and I by myself,
whatever clothing I wanted and, and
it's funny, this point in my life, like,
you know, Shit's pretty tight, so
you got, you got to really like,
like unless I need it, you need
a sugar daddy? No, I'm not.
I'm not that kind of girl. Listen, I that
kind of girl. Joe. I know you're not,
but let's pretend you were.
Don't you pressure me?
Let's come up with a fake sugar
daddy. Some perfect scenario
type like a podcast empire guys.
Did you like guys with a
Werewolf facial hair? Very here.
You need to be able to physically
pick me up. That's true.
There should be to tire throw football
and you're in the desert with a hurt
ankle in the desert. The man's got to be
able to carry you. You dead. Mm. Yeah,
because otherwise you're just
going to lay there and die.
I hurt my ankle all the time, so I can't
carry you. Yeah. What the fuck, you know?
Oh Man.
Should be able to carry as a woman.
[inaudible] surely carrier through the
desert and these over the shoulder.
Actually I'm style.
I really have no idea what I want and
we'll find out as time goes on. Oh,
we talking for real?
You play Oh, red band.
Multiyear Ohio. That's my favorite.
Yeah, that's a great song.
I messed up the lyrics the other night.
Oh No, I felt like, what did you,
did I fucking freestyle when
you saw, um, what's her name?
Fuck up the national anthem. What's
her name? Christina Aguilera.
When you saw that, did you wince like
when you like am I see a comedian bomb?
I can't even watch. You know what? No,
it's, it happens. It's like, well that,
that's d no disrespect. I don't want to,
I don't want to fucking dog on anybody,
but like, but what, like here's
the thing, like we hadn't, again,
we hadn't slept for a couple of days,
like Ben,
like exhausted and sometimes sometimes
like you get comfortable and then you
zone out and then you're like, fuck,
fuck, fuck. And then you just, and I did,
I freestyle then it made
sense and I was like,
maybe those lyrics would have been better
than the original ones we'd written.
It could be any number of things though,
right?
Cause it was like I'm a get you Sucka Mama
said knock you out Ohio today. Was it?
We good cause that what you did now what
did you do that was like judging me.
Go for it. Um, no. I, I literally
just started saying worth.
No, you didn't say oh
no. That's hilarious.
You think tough enough. I was
just like, Oh God. Oh God.
Laughs stuff, stuff, stuff,
stuff. Tab Click. Thank God I can
screw up on the guitar now and I get
terrible. No one notice. Yeah.
When you're talking about it in front of
a million people, but they don't know.
They don't even know who we are.
They're like, there's a girl with,
with hair and on her head
and she's got a banjo.
That's all they saw.
Okay.
This is a crazy thing
about show crow though too,
is that she goes up there and she,
she has this brain tumor.
She's a brain tumor right now. Is it a
city have to be operated? It's benign,
but she's, she forgets stuff
so she has um, what it's true.
She owns up to it. That's the thing.
She goes up there and she's like,
if she forgets a word,
she says I got a brain tumor.
But the fact that she goes up on stage,
um,
with the knowledge that she could
forget the lyrics are not knowing.
I think that takes a huge amount of
lady balls. Lady lady balls hitting.
Yes, it definitely does. Yeah.
It's just an amazing thing.
80 bucks does turn you on,
Brian.
Let's talk about that.
What else are you feeling ladies?
Triangles.
Nags,
nags, cut off. I started drinking.
Awesome. You did good for you.
Did you have some of the hunting JD?
No, I had a fake captain. Morgan's
staff. That, is that the stuff that
you said you were going to drink? Oh,
that's what I was talking about.
I didn't know what that means.
I've never heard of this.
Delicious hammered the last
time we were on your show.
It was a great time.
We had a great time too.
Okay, good. A manager just emailed us.
I thought he's going to be
like step acting like idiots.
Why would you ever listen to anybody?
Don't ever listen to anybody tells you.
Definitely can't get it right you guys,
you know what you're doing.
Just trust your instincts. Go with
the flow and use the force. Luke,
we're gonna finish this bottle of
booze and go streaking down Pasadena.
That's who you really want to do.
But if you do it,
it means that you really wanted to do it.
And then she just fucking do it.
I don't think I've ever gone
streaking good then. Don't do it.
If it doesn't feel like that's
what you should be doing.
There's some crazy bitch and wants to
take off her clothes and run down the
street. What's wrong with that? I say
nothing. Keep my boots on. You know,
as long as you're not hurt,
I don't know.
That's a good mood and you
should probably just one screen.
So naked with that sounds so dangerous.
Hey Joe, can I hit that joint? Um,
I don't know where it is.
Oh,
you think we should be higher
for listening to his songs?
I want to talk about the crazy dude. A
crazy dude. What are you talking about?
I really, I can I read an email?
Yes, please. Wait a minute.
Are you sure you want
to do this? I am. No,
you were talking about crazy encounters
with people. This is fun to me.
This is really funny.
The other day when we had our epic
show I was telling you about in, um,
in Santa Rosa,
California,
there was a gentleman that was front and
center and he was really enthusiastic
to say the least and was so,
so very complimentary and
genuine at the end of the show.
And he had said,
hey,
I would love it if you guys came and
played a show at my house one day.
And originally we were like,
it's kind of weird, you know,
people say that you're like,
you know, okay, well that's,
that's a nice sentiment,
but we want to be careful with
situations like that. And then,
then the guy's like, I can, you know,
you'd be playing after Steve Miller,
Steve Miller band. And he's
like, he's like, you know, I can,
I can afford to pay you. And basically
saying, let them that he's got, you know,
some, some muon and he
can, he can pay us. Right.
So then, so then he gets
a little weird. Oh and
Oh God, where is it? I kind of got
to blow up this guy's spot. No, no,
I'm not naming any names, but um, it,
it got really, Ben, do you have it?
There it is. Oh No. Did he
respond? Okay. So, so he,
he was a little Kooky, like he was dancing
around the front of the stage and um,
um, then he sends, he talked to our
management and our manager was like,
this could be really great for you guys.
And then he sent an email to our
manager and it goes like this, Jeff,
about honey honey and the lead singer.
She really needs some help with
the tire starting with her boots.
She can be one really knocked out gal
if she dressed right as she might have
noticed. I'm covered with women.
So that is not my interest.
Her talent is about the lead guitars.
That would be been his humility on
stage is a great plus about the drummer.
He should be shown new licks from some
of the greats as he has the potential to
be one himself about eight for the date
that he wanted us to play the bubble if
you have any.
Anyway,
so he had this big fucking spiel about
my boots being a problem and I think my
boots are fine.
Really.
Are you really addressing those?
I mean they smell a little more problems.
More problems [inaudible] right.
Thank you for calling
us out about your shoes.
It's our fault we let him in.
We were hopeful.
I was literally planning on playing a
show by myself cause Ben couldn't make it
and then he told me that I wasn't cool
because I'm going to it better crazy
people antenna and I said,
you're not cool because it's
pretty obvious with this
dude. This guy was great.
He writes in the front row. Well then
you should said totally hold though.
He owed us.
Well it sounds like a rich douche bag.
There's a lot of those out there.
It's normal.
You calling us out cause you're right.
We should,
we should move on from anyone that hates
so silly. What does he give a fuck?
What you're dressed like?
That's what you'd like to dress.
I think that's what pisses me off.
It's like you're an idiot. You can't,
you can't influence.
Like you can't say,
oh you know you should be in
stilettos and with your fucking toes.
Just to prove a point where only boots
should wear what you want to wear.
Red Lizard suit,
non creative people always
feel like they can fix things.
Like they could step
in and fix like little,
you just see me and he
needs a fucking haircut.
This car because it's like your
problem is the problem isn't the just
distribution of music.
This young man with his crazy hair
girl needs to lose weight. No one needs
anything. Look at that. A Dell check.
I mean it's just all you need is a sound.
You need the amazing sound from
your voice. People fucking love you.
Look at Amy Winehouse cracked
out to the end. All fucked up.
Missing teeth. Amazing
voice. Everybody loved her.
She didn't look good. She looked crazy.
She looks a lot better now. Shut.
Cut. Shut up. Right for at
least 15 minutes. You asshole.
You son of a bitch.
Um,
at least like three to four
years off your life from Karma.
She was so interesting because it
was like retro but not, you know,
like that Rehab Song. What a beautiful
song man. She had an incredible voice
but that seems, sorry, I
was just going to say I was,
I was watching her live last night. It
was just thinking about how, you know,
you see a lot of groups
that are successful kind
of redoing an old sound and
even if they do a great, it's,
it's, you know, it can be great,
but she kinda contemporize it. She did
something completely different. Yeah.
That's amazing.
So much like we were talking
about earlier about like emotions,
like traveling through the lyrics and it
doesn't even matter what you're singing
about if like that the, the
emotion in your mind, you know,
comes through the words.
There's like this weird effect
that a song has and with her,
like she totally nailed that man that I
remember seeing that Rehab video where
she's sort of swaying on that microphone
while she's saying it. You're like,
God damn, that bitch has
got some talent. You know,
she just had this weird new thing,
new thing, next level. Oh Yeah,
look at this new thing. Crazy
voice talking about she's
not going to go to rehab.
She's thinking about not going to rehab.
Yeah.
By that I mean that was the truthful,
you know,
what's kind of sort of like heartbreaking
and beautiful about it at the same
time as that, that was like, that
wasn't somebody being like, Hey,
let me write a pop song that everybody's
going to want to buy and listen to and
sounds really trendy right now.
That wasn't some sort of generic kind
of regurgitation of what's already been
done. That was, that was somebody
being honest in, you know, it's,
uh, it's very interesting and
powerful because that woman, um,
if I think if, if you were to
look really closely, didn't,
didn't really care too much about
the other side of like the attention.
I think she just really wanted to be
loved and she was an artist, you know,
and cause, you know, she, she talks a
lot about heartbreak or talked and, um,
there, there's a really
interesting thing that, um,
I think about a lot. I saw this
really sad youtube video of, um,
when she kind of got carried off stage,
she was playing in Serbia,
and this is about a week before she died.
She'd started a tour and she came
out and was like, hello, Athens.
And she's in Serbia. And, um, it's
like clearly inebriated on, you know,
beyond belief and falling over,
can't, can't sing. And um, you know,
it's an interesting thing to think about
the fact that no one put her into some
sort of facility immediately
upon that circumstance alone.
But you know, when you think about all of
her art, it was like, people were like,
yeah, I love the song as a
club hit. It was a radio hit,
single number one billboard,
everything.
And then if you really don't look closely,
it's like that was, is that the Ah,
Shit,
you know? Um, it's like that was real.
Um, and you know not to, to bring it
down low. Yeah. I think that's a show.
Um, yeah, she starts taking her shoes
off and shit. Oh yeah, I saw this.
And you know, it's just like
some, somebody just take her home.
She's got a rob bad mixture. Yeah. Give
her a cup of coffee, get it back out.
So Redman, say something funny, little
slap on the ass, you know, look, um,
do you, do you see that shit and then
you see it as like, well, you know,
there's the pitfalls of a fame.
Avoid these roadblocks or do you ever
think that that could ever happen to you?
You could become Super Amy Winehouse
style famous, really solid family.
I got a really great
foundation from Ohio stock or Italian.
They're actually here.
I'm actually late for dinner, but
yeah, there's my folks and my,
I've got three sisters and some really
incredible friends and, and Ben, you know,
and you guys are going to keep
it together no matter what.
Even if you get Jz type famous,
don't you become a crack head on my watch?
If you guys have a giant all like yacht
and dancing girls on the yacht and I
come visit you and I'll be,
I'll be meditating time,
we'll have all the fucking
naked chicks and all the booze,
but we'll be like zen and meditating
on our juice cleanses and shit.
Don't think the girl supposed to be naked.
That makes it a little classless.
They're free to do whatever they
want though. We're not going to stop.
We won't stop them from going
topless if they don't want 10 lines.
Translucent, undergarments,
translucent undergo.
Let's not fucking discriminate here.
Do you remember when
that Tan Lines Brian,
remember that she member Tan lines
when Tan lines were hot? Huh?
10 lines are still hot
under the playboy bunny.
Never did that. Never do that. Good for
you. But a lot of girls in high school,
I did good for them to
expressing them.
You know what sucks about
burned yesterday cause I was
walking outside without Brian.
What sucks about spray tanning?
Because your bed looks
like Garfield died in it.
It's like an orange streak in your,
what do you think's going to happen
once they have the ability to actually
physically altered the way you look?
Because they're working on that now.
Like they're working on all sorts of
different, no, no. Genetic engineering
change. People's genomes change.
Whatever that is. The DNA change,
whatever the fuck they
gonna be able to change.
But they're gonna be able
to do something where they
could turn black like a gorilla.
That'd be cool to be black like a every
Friday, like black Friday wouldn't be the,
you keep changing back and forth.
Imagine if he tried to keep changing it
back and forth. Your Dna just kept going
more and more fucked up.
You like,
I want to try to be an old man for one
day just to see what it's going to be
like. Oh Benjamin button on their asses.
Yeah, I do that. It's called October.
Twice. What? Justin
October. Moving on. Yeah,
we've lost ourselves there. I know.
Where are you going to take mommy?
You're going to go to the olive garden.
Oh,
let me tell you something. Even
know what just happened. Come on.
They don't got trolled. This is, he
does it. He mentions all of garden,
a verbal trial. He even mentions
the olive garden banks. It's cute.
He sneaks on my family.
My family owns an Italian restaurant.
Did it's like son of a
bitch. 40 years. Yeah,
my grandparents started so
they rate the off garden.
Well they don't hate the olive garden,
but it's like,
that's like saying um hey guys, thanks
for coming to California. Let's go to,
let's go to Mcdonald's. Yeah, but they
can appreciate the value. You know,
you're saving their daughter some
money cause I'm going to have endless
breadsticks there. Red Van, red van.
Once again, you're put back in timeout.
Okay. Fellow Ohio stock. I know,
that's why I'm saying let's stick with
the local businesses. Oh, he's a camel.
He's from a different part of my castle.
I do like white castle and
in and out all east coast.
That's not just Ohio, right. John,
can you do me big chains now?
I'm a fan of the chain and woman.
I tried gardening of all the states.
I think honestly I'm going
to Texas and Ohio. Oh wait.
Oh well there's a lot of them out here.
They stick together. These Ohio freaks.
They like resilience. We do. We're
mobilizing. We're here in the west coast.
They call it the Midwest
Mafia. Harlow. Um,
so will you play Ohio and then we'll
wrap this bitch up, bring it into shore.
I don't know if I'm entail.
Oh Hi. That's good. That's real good.
You want to do a
one to one
folks have the same song and dance
downtown bars and cheap Romaine's getting
off,
not getting farm low.
Watch this freeway.
Turn it.
Just a flick you a the
APP or crass cha and down.
How you can bring back to how it was.
I act and you act tough.
Where you say phase a car you love.
You don't want to give me
somehow find someone does.
I swear his summers
on your streets when Lapierre feet.
She still got the call?
Kohler? No. Oh, hi.
Oh,
Hi
Daddy.
I got swept up and family pride truth
that the truth came in and hung me out.
Face down in the dirt out.
Dig the ground.
Hi. Oh, hi.
Oh, hi. Oh,
okay.
You are a glass window display.
Praise to pray a hand me
down. Thrift store. Trey.
He got you pay.
Ah,
please.
Still not favorite songs.
Okay,
awesome. I'm a huge fan of
that song. Oh Man. Listen,
we have to do something where every time
you guys are going to go on the road
and no matter where you are, you've
got to let us know so we can tweet it.
Anytime you're, you're coming
to anywhere, let us know.
Put it up and we'll tweet it and we'll
talk about it on the podcast and send me
an email.
Let me know where are you going to be.
People want to know because I keep,
I keep getting all these tweets and people
ask me on Facebook like how do we go
to see them? Where are they? Where
are they going to be? October.
We have a tour in October,
right honey, honey, band.com.
Yup. Honey, honey, ban.com.
Yeah, and honey, honey band on Twitter.
And you guys are fucking awesome.
So I'm so psyched that we're friends.
It's so cool to have you guys on the
shoot the shit and hang out and just say
thank you so much for having so fun and
I'm so happy to hear that so many people
that listen to the podcast came out
see you guys and was incredible ways.
That feels beautiful.
We're going to make it more,
we're going to clean the packet. You
guys are awesome. You so talented and uh,
I'm just, uh, I'm honored to be friends
with you guys. Really? Oh Man. Beautiful.
Have you file them? You dirty bitches,
honey. Honey ban on Twitter and um,
follow MML follow alien ware MMA.
They're the ones who supplied us with
these groovy ass space age type gaming
computers.
Check them out on Twitter and red band.
It's red n and my name is Joe Rogan and
a the Joe Rogan experience podcast of
course is brought to you by
[inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I t and checkout some Alpha brain son.
Get yourself some brain supplements.
All of it is explained on on at.com
and if you use the code name Rogan,
you'll save 10% off all supplements.
We also have kettle bells battle ropes,
and you need that shit.
If you want to be a manly type man,
trust me on it.com go Holla at your boy.
I'll see you guys.
We've got an epic epic week
tomorrow in mortal technique. What?
What Wednesday Robb Wolf,
author of the Paleo Diet Son.
We're going to break down.
Why?
It's good to be a caveman and then
Maynard James Keenan on Friday.
Holla at your boy.
I might faint for.
I'm going to have a good fucking
time this week. You dirty bitches.
We love you all and thank you
everyone in Calgary. Oh, before we go,
I just to play this back for the people
in Calgary, because this was for real,
one of the craziest fucking crowds.
We had two crazy crowds.
We sold out this place called the Jack
Singer concert hall. And this is a,
this is me going on stage and coward
cause it's just so ridiculous.
Hello.
This is probably the craziest
crowd I've ever been.
There's like I've ever been in front
of my life because people are insane.
Okay.
They're fucking savages.
So the crowd was so crazy to 20 dudes
got kicked out for being hammered and
heckling.
And at the end of the show
I get a standing ovation and
when everybody stands up,
one guy pulls his dick out and starts
a on the people in front of them. Yes.
And there's a video of people
punching him in the face.
This is a video of that guy
getting punched in the face.
It's on my Twitter feed from a couple
of, couple of days ago. It was awesome.
Calgary,
you people with a shit even just look 20
Douche bags out of a crowd to crowds of
2000 people. It's fucking great
numbers. People are going, I'm sorry.
Those people ruined your time at Calgary.
Nobody ruined anything.
I had a great fucking time.
It was amazing.
Calgary was the shit and the guys
who got kicked out, you know,
they just got too drunk.
The intermission was a terrible idea to,
there's an information. Anyway, so it
was over. We'll see you guys smile.
You're not your calling.
Okay.
Yeah.